[Música]
estoy de regreso con ustedes porque a
partir de este momento inicia el
cubrimiento especial de france 24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez y hoy los
acompañaré durante la transmisión y el
análisis de la última jornada de la
convención nacional republicana esta
noche en eeuu terminan los cuatro días
en los que se reafirmó la candidatura de
donald trump quien aspira a la
reelección presidencial este próximo 3
de noviembre estamos escuchando en este
momento a mitch mcconnell el líder de la
mayoría en el senado
y dejemos que ellos decidan cómo debemos
vivir nuestras vidas quieren decirles
cuando trabajar cuando sus hijos pueden
ir a la escuela quieren ponerles
demasiados impuestos y enviarles quieren
decirles qué tipo de auto pueden
conducir qué fuentes de información son
creíbles e incluso cuentos trabajador
cuántas hamburguesas pueden comerse
quieren desfinanciar a la policía y
quitarles su derecho a la segunda
enmienda quieren salud gratis para los
ilegales y sin ofrecer protección para
nada para los no nacidos quieren dejar
llenar la corte suprema con liberales y
quieren hacer todo esto haciendo que el
pantano como tal de washington 10 y se
ha el estado 51 con dos senadores más no
podemos cambiar el daño que ellos han
generado por eso los demócratas han
pasado una semana diciéndonos quién es
joe by del no lo que pretende hacer me
siento inmensamente
orgulloso del trabajo que hemos hecho en
el senado hemos sido un muro en contra
de la agenda de nancy pelosi como el
presidente son no seremos intimidados
por los intentos de los medios para
destruirlos las instituciones hablaremos
en nombre de millones de estadounidenses
cuyas historias no son contadas en los
periódicos cuyas luchas son igualmente
reales apoyaremos a las familias
mientras derrotamos al coronavirus y
haremos que la economía sea la envidia
del mundo lo que está fuego nunca ha
sido más alto por eso les pido que
apoyen a los candidatos al senado
alrededor del país y reflejamos a mi
amigo el presidente de donald trump
[Música]
hoy como las noches anteriores vamos a
estar escuchando las voces más
representativas del partido republicano
vamos a escucharlo a ver cuáles son
algunos de los más importantes para el
cierre con la casa blanca como telón de
fondo ofrecerá su discurso donald trump
actual presidente de los eeuu y el
mandatario será precedido por su hija
ivanka trump asesora de la presidencia y
considerada por muchos como su mano
derecha
también vimos cómo participó hace unos
segundos como orador mitch mcconnell el
líder de la mayoría republicana del
senado y rudolph giuliani ex alcalde de
nueva york
mientras que continuamos escuchando los
discursos y las intervenciones
preparadas para esta noche vamos a ir a
nueva york con nuestra corresponsal ama
mensah la mamen
buenas noches para usted y que podemos
esperar para las próximas horas en este
cierre de la convención nacional
republicana
sin muy buenas noches desde nueva york
pues esta es la última jornada de una
convención republicana que desde luego
ha sido muy mucho menos virtual que la
que veíamos la semana anterior de los
demócratas hoy por fin es el turno del
discurso del presidente un discurso que
se espera pues que toque todos los temas
que en estos momentos son de interés
tanto para él como para los ciudadanos
estadounidenses hablará de empleo pondrá
cifras encima de la mesa dice que ha
creado 10 millones de empleos sí que es
cierto que en febrero la tasa de
desempleo estaba un 35 por ciento que es
la más baja desde 1969 y en estos
momentos en julio la tasa estaba casi un
poquito por encima del 10% así que
seguramente se centre en esa economía en
ese empleo pre a kobe de 19 hablará
también de inmigración hablará también
de las relaciones con china hablará
también de educación sanidad hablará
también de los disturbios y defenderá la
labor de la policía lo hará como decías
desde el jardín sur de la casa blanca
al menos 1000 personas algo que la
verdad contrasta mucho con lo que hemos
visto en la convención demócrata y sobre
todo lo que recomienda en la mayoría de
autoridades de los estados y es que no
se reúna una gran multitud de personas
en washington de hecho en algunas zonas
las reuniones de más de 50 personas
están incluso prohibidas en los días
anteriores hemos visto poco uso de
mascarillas y veremos a ver qué ocurre
esta noche también es interesante que
escucharemos como decías hemos escuchado
ya a estas dos personalidades dentro del
partido demócrata escucharemos también
hay banca a su hija y escucharemos
también figuras destacadas dentro del
partido republicano que quizá esta noche
veamos un poquito más de la agenda que
tienen prevista para los próximos cuatro
años algo que donald trump ha acusado a
los demócratas de que en esta convención
no se puso encima de la mesa ninguna
acción concreta sobre lo que van a hacer
en estos cuatro años de momento tampoco
lo hemos visto en el bando republicano
sino más lejos de escuchábamos al
al líder de la mayoría en el senado en
estos momentos que explicaba un poquito
lo que todo el mundo quiere escuchar
pero no explicaba cómo lo van a hacer
eso se espera que lo cuente esta noche
el presidente dona en trama así que
desde luego va a ser pues un colofón
final y una noche de muchas sorpresas
también como como donald trama espera y
ya había anunciado bueno mamen y otra de
las figuras que hoy van a hablar y sobre
la que usted nos puede contextualizar
mucho más es rudy giuliani que podemos
esperar de su discurso según lo que
hemos visto en el pasado y durante esta
campaña tan atípica en medio de la
pandemia del cobi 19
si rudy giuliani hará su intervención
también esta noche fue ex alcalde de la
ciudad de nueva york y acabó
convirtiéndose en una persona muy
cercana al presidente de donald trump lo
vimos durante el juicio político es
impeachment que tuvo lugar el año pasado
se ha convertido en su abogado personal
y rudy giuliani viene a esta convención
a hablar bueno atacar sobre todo a baida
va a intentar poner encima de la mesa va
a intentar
acusarlo de bueno de haber de no haber
de no haber realizado digamos lo que
tenía que haber hecho a nivel político y
sabemos que tuvo una figura muy
destacada durante el juicio político del
año pasado y eso es lo que vamos a ver
también va a intentar acusar a la
familia de corrupción y por supuesto va
a pelear por el presidente de donald
trump y de nuevo insistir en esa idea
que ya hemos visto en los días
anteriores acerca de lo que puede
ocurrir si a los demócratas consiguen
llegar a la presidencia
este 3 de noviembre
regreso con usted en unos minutos le
pido que se quede con nosotros ya
regresamos para seguir haciendo avances
pero también está con nosotros diana
castañeda desde la ciudad de washington
dice que hoy es protagonista de la
última noche de la convención nacional
republicana y diana quiero comenzar
preguntándole por un tema que ya tocó
nuestra colega mamen y es la polémica
que existe porque se planea que haya una
especie de celebración al final de esta
convención con fuegos artificiales cerca
de algunos edificios emblemáticos
gubernamentales allí en washington dc y
pues esto iría según han dicho los
demócratas en contra de las
restricciones por la pandemia
así es no solamente en contra de las
restricciones debido a la situación a la
crisis de salud que afronta los eeuu
sino también a las leyes y tradiciones
establecidas durante campañas
electorales hay muchas críticas por
parte de los demócratas de por qué el
presidente está utilizando edificios
gubernamentales como es la casa blanca
para realizar funciones partidistas
dentro de una campaña electoral es algo
que se había respetado es una regla que
habían cumplido anteriormente muchos
candidatos pero también los demócratas
están buscando encabezar una
investigación al interior del comité de
asuntos exteriores de la cámara de
representantes en cabeza del congresista
el castro porque el secretario d
he estado en los eeuu pompeo decidió
también realizar su discurso para la
convención desde israel utilizando
recursos públicos que pagan las personas
a través de sus impuestos en los eeuu
para hacer este mensaje con fines
políticos y electorales lo cual viola
las reglas internas del departamento de
estado que dice que no pueden tomar
partido o favor hacia alguno de los
partidos existentes dentro de elecciones
y por supuesto llama la atención que
estamos viendo en las imágenes de esta
convención una gran celebración por
parte del presidente de donald trump
los demócratas aseguraban que es porque
no tuvo la posibilidad tener una gran
convención
y que no se está siguiendo este
protocolo de normas y protección en las
sillas están muy unidas
no hay una distancia digamos esperada
como protección en la mayoría de los
asistentes no están utilizando máscaras
pero es el común que hemos visto durante
todos estos días de la convención
republicana por ejemplo con el discurso
que dio la primera dama en la casa
blanca en los jardines de las rosas en
donde tampoco tenían máscaras a
diferencia de lo que vimos en la
convención demócrata donde tanto joe
biden como kamala harris tenían su
máscara y no estrecharon manos al final
de sus respectivos discursos y cuando
fueron confirmados y tampoco realizaron
eventos esa es la gran diferencia entre
las dos convenciones que esta convención
republicana fue imitar virtual mitad
presencial se transmitió todas en línea
pero la convención demócrata fue
completamente
virtual y se grabaron más de mil vídeos
con anticipación con las voces que vimos
para evitar precisamente que se fueran a
dar en casos de propagación del virus
tratando de realizar esta convención
bueno diana usted estaba hablando nos
acerca del tema de que donald trump se
dirija a la ciudadanía desde la casa
blanca entonces hay una denuncia de
ilegalidad que lideran los demócratas
por esta intervención sin embargo existe
la ley
que protegería al mandatario en su
intervención y que también está
contemplada para proteger al
vicepresidente por favor explíquenos
para aclarar si estas denuncias de
ilegalidad tienen un lugar
bueno básicamente
el punto de discordia es si un
presidente en curso de funciones en sus
funciones en pleno ejerciendo como
mandatario de los eeuu puede hacerlo
para muchos es un vacío legal que no
queda muy claro en donde el mandatario
en curso si podría hacerlo pero desde el
punto de vista ético no es lo indicado
así que digamos que en el aspecto de que
se realice esta parte de la convención
en el ala sur de la casa blanca y se
hayan realizado digamos estas planeación
es para festividades
esta esta medida protegería al
presidente al vicepresidente pero en el
caso del secretario de estado es
completamente diferente porque el
departamento de estado funciona de
manera separada se supone que es en una
organización que no debe tener ningún
fin hacia algún partido incluso el
secretario conteo había enviado un
correo la semana pasada a los miembros y
trabajadores federales del departamento
de estado para que no se involucrarán no
participarán en ningún evento ni tampoco
hicieran comentarios en favor de ninguno
de los dos partidos porque se trataba de
un tema electoral así que en el lado del
secretario de estado y el vídeo que
realizo si se podría dar una
investigación al interior de la cámara
de representantes pero en teoría es más
una violación ética que legal lo que
estamos viendo por parte del presidente
trump viena gracias a usted igual que
ameneh le pido que se quede con nosotros
ya regresamos para seguir discutiendo
desde las ciudades de washington y en
nueva york'
el avance de esta convención nacional
republicana y es el momento de darle la
bienvenida a nuestras invitadas de esta
noche para el análisis es un placer
darles bienvenida a antonella martí
quien es analista política y directora
del center for latin america en
washington dice y también está con
nosotros maría herrera ella es estratega
republicana doctor en ciencia jurídica y
vicepresidenta de la asamblea hispana
del partido republicano en florida
también desde washington de si contamos
con un y jensen analista política y
asesora de albright stonebridge group
bienvenidos las tres gracias por estar
con nosotros y bueno la pregunta que es
la obligada de esta noche comienzo por
antonella que podemos esperar del
discurso de donald trump
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación y
muy buenas noches la verdad que yo
recién me quedo con dos comentarios de
las corresponsales que hablaron recién
por un lado creo que hay que remarcar
este aspecto de que no se han visto
hasta el momento
en el discurso tal vez acciones
concretas no de partes de lo que sería
el programa de gobierno si llegase a
ganar el presidente
donald trump y por otro lado creo que
también tenemos que tener en cuenta no
es un detalle menor lo que estaban
conversando recién respecto de el uso de
los recursos públicos oficiales para
dirigirse a los a los estadounidenses en
medio de una campaña pero claramente yo
creo que hay ciertas herramientas que
creo que también se pueden ver no
solamente por parte de esta campaña de
donald trump sino también por parte del
otro candidato demócrata
byd en el que comparte no creo que hay
herramientas que comparten en esta
campaña uno lo puede ver tanto en el
discurso de biden como trump y primero
creo que esta concepción del uso del
miedo
muchas veces como primera herramienta
para mostrar quizás lo peor del
contrincante yo creo que esto es uno que
algo que incluso uno lo puede ver en las
plataformas web de cada uno de los de
los de los contrincantes que se van a
encontrar ahora
donde no hay realmente este un plan
concreto sino más bien un ataque
constante hacia el otro creo que eso es
un aspecto que tenemos que tener en
cuenta gracias a antonella por su
intervención y vamos a invitar a nuestra
audiencia a que observé las imágenes que
a esta hora se producen a las afueras de
la casa blanca donde en este momento hay
una protesta anti trump al mismo tiempo
que está avanzando la convención
republicana y sobre estas imágenes
quisiera preguntarles a nuestras 12
invitadas a maría herrera y muni hensen
cuál es su opinión porque hay un
fenómeno que se ha dado en los últimos
meses y es que han ido cambiando los
apoyos entre algunos votantes
republicanos si viene el índice de
aprobación en el partido sigue siendo
alto para donald trump o también ha
aumentado la disidencia dentro de su
propio partido se publicaron la semana
pasada 3
abiertas en las que byd en obtuvo el
respaldo de más de 160 personas que en
el pasado trabajaron para republicanos
como el ex presidente george w.bush o
para mitt romney o para john mccain esto
fue reportado por el 'new york times' y
también por el portal político porque
ese cambio de apoyos y voy primero con
maría herrera
[Aplausos]
bueno buenas noches en primer lugar me
gustaría destacar que estas protestas
que están llevando a cabo con todo eeuu
bajo mi punto de vista no están
justificada puesto que vivimos en un
país democrático donde hay y se debe
defender el orden y la ley y por
supuesto también la justicia el el hecho
de que haya personalidades y
funcionarios o antiguos presidentes que
apoyen ahora al presidente valle es
respetable sin embargo mantenemos que
hay una minoría silenciosa que yo
considero mayoría que no se ha
pronunciado por temor a las represalias
que vemos que acontecen todos los días y
a lo largo de nuestros trabajos y en
nuestras vidas pública que por el simple
hecho de expresar nuestra opinión se nos
censura incluso hay personas que se
desecha del trabajo y eso también es de
destacar que incluso algunos
intelectuales de izquierdas han escrito
cartas quejándose sobre la libertad de
expresión
el riesgo que vivimos en este país a la
hora de defender al actual presidente oa
cualquier persona conservadora que no
esté de acuerdo con este globalismo y el
progresismo que que nos amenaza
muy buenas noches bienvenida y por favor
cuál es su interpretación sobre estas
protestas y sobre los cambios de apoyos
buenas noches y primero quiero empezar
diciendo que es un gusto compartir un
panel con panelistas mujeres es una será
un placer esta noche lo que estamos
viendo en televisión es un capítulo de
lo que en este momento representa el
reality show de donald trump que hoy
entra a su cuarto y último día y para
crear esta producción televisiva donald
trump ignoró la realidad que está justo
afuera de su casa a metros de la casa
blanca y lo que existe en todas partes
de eeuu y ha ignorado varios eventos de
talla nacional en esta noche el primero
y el más inmediato la el huracán que
está en este momento azotando el sur del
país que a lo mínimo se esperaba iba a
reducir un poco en la agenda del día de
hoy para dedicar un poco de tiempo y
respeto a las personas que están
viviendo este horrible desastre natural
lo segundo el covilhá
con la falta de prácticamente en todos
los días se ha ignorado el cob in se ha
hablado el joven como si fuera algo del
pasado y no se están cumpliendo como se
comentaron los protocolos y lo tercero
el estallido social que está ocurriendo
en este momento en eeuu esta batalla
contra el racismo esta manifestación
democrática pública que se está viendo y
algunas veces con unas consecuencias muy
muy trágicas y muy violentas en las
ciudades del país el no reconocer y no
darle realmente una respuesta a este
grupo de americanos que es un grupo
grande cada vez creciente es algo que es
bastante contradictorio en esta noche
donde los republicanos y el presidente
de la república está de fiesta
bueno usted ha tocado un punto muy
importante y es el contexto que le tocó
a la convención republicana para para
desarrollar sus discursos mientras que
afuera en el país se tenemos los
contagios por el codo y 19 que continúan
en aumento y no sobra recordar que eeuu
sigue ocupando el primer lugar en
contagios del mundo tenemos también la
llegada del huracán laura al golfo que
ya bueno también vale mencionarlo se
degradó a tormenta tropical y por
supuesto las protestas raciales que se
reavivaron en todo el país después del
ataque que fue sufrido por jake blake y
por eso quisiera preguntarle nuevamente
a maría herrera nuestra estratega
republicana invitada la noche de hoy
para que nos diga cuál es su percepción
sobre el manejo que se ha dado dentro de
los discursos de esta convención durante
las últimas noches a todos estos eventos
que quiéralo o no pues tocan muchísimo
la estrategia política de donald trump o
que quiere quedarse en la casa blanca
por otros cuatro años
bueno yo estoy en desacuerdo con lo que
ha dicho nuestra compañera demócrata
porque yo he escuchado los largos de
estos días como los diferentes ponentes
definitivamente han expresado sus
condolencias no hacia las personas que
han fallecido por el coronavirus ha
mostrado a su determinación para luchar
al igual que lo hizo desde el minuto 1
el presidente no como siempre en la
línea de el lado demócrata tenemos a
personas que nunca están satisfecha con
nada de lo que haga el presidente para
ellos todo es un 'reality show' pero es
la excusa perfecta siempre para no
celebrar la gran nación en la que
vivimos la gran historia que somos uno
de los países que llevamos luz al resto
del mundo que somos un ejemplo yo soy
abogada soy concretamente abogada de
inmigración y por supuesto que nuestro
sistema de justicia tiene fallas pero yo
comparo y viajo y veo y creo que
no me equivoco en decir que este es uno
de los mejores países y que sí es verdad
que hay cosas que se pueden mejorar
somos un auténtico ejemplo por otra
parte en el estallido social yo creo que
hay que estar claro de que nada de lo
que está ocurriendo es fruto de la
casualidad por supuesto detrás tenemos a
un george soros tenemos una fundación a
hillary clinton de una izquierda que
financia a todos estos movimientos
marxistas que juega con los sentimientos
y la sensibilidad de millones de
ciudadanos y en un país en el que
definitivamente tenemos que tener muy
claro que se hará justicia que los
pilares y la separación de poderes
existe y que no hay que temerle a las
fuerzas y cuerpo de seguridad porque si
vemos las estadísticas te dejamos claro
que los datos estadísticos no se
corresponden con la mayoría de las
declaraciones que hacen estos grupos
marxistas hay fallos dentro de la
policía desde el
un uso excesivo de la fuerza desde luego
en ciertos casos en la minoría de casos
pero también tenemos que trabajar para
la educación de esos millones de
personas que no alcanzan a entender las
leyes que asisten a todos los ciudadanos
no sólo a aquellos que delinquen sino
también a las víctimas a las víctimas de
violencia doméstica como hemos visto los
casos en las víctimas de robos y fraudes
por desgracia eso se repite y las
personas también tienen que colaborar
con las fuerzas y orden de seguridad
quisiera darle la palabra munilla
nuevamente porque siguiendo la línea de
maría herrera sobre las reacciones que
se han presentado después de todo este
2020 que ha estado inundado de marchas
contra el racismo y contra la brutalidad
policial una crítica muy fuerte que ha
surgido especialmente en las últimas
semanas es contra la decisión de donald
trump de enviar a miembros de la guardia
nacional para proteger las ciudades y
para restablecer el orden esto es una
decisión que bueno desde el punto de
vista republicano es necesaria para
evitar que aumente más la violencia y lo
que denuncia a la señora maría herrera
de grupos marxistas pero también para
otros es una reacción desmedida y que lo
que hace es empeorar aún más la tensión
racial en eeuu
en efecto en la noticia más triste de
todas es que desde la muerte de georg
floyd solamente han aumentado los casos
de violencia policial es decir que todas
estas protestas y la reacción de la
policía no está generando ningún tipo de
cambio de comportamiento y sin duda lo
que está pasando en este momento no es
un movimiento marxista ni necesariamente
obedece a una ideología de ningún tipo
es un descontento es un descontento de
las personas de todos los colores y de
edades porque son marchas muy diversas y
es un descontento con la injusticia es
un descontento con el racismo y con la
exclusión y se está convirtiendo no
solamente en una serie de protestas sino
en un movimiento que a través de las
redes sociales y a través de las
ciudades se ha propagado y ha canalizado
también la rabia y la falta de
satisfacción con un gobierno que no
tiene como prioridad las minorías no
tiene como prioridad atender las
necesidades de quienes buscan más
justicia que está montando realmente una
realidad
culpando a estos grupos descontentos de
una ideología que carecen o no tienen
una ideología específica hay gente de
diferentes
desde diferentes caminos y de diferentes
orígenes es decir lo que está pasando en
eeuu no se puede ignorar y las imágenes
que estamos viendo en este momento son
lo más claro la casa blanca ignorando de
espaldas a la gente tratando de montar
una película que no existe esto es
ficción y lo que estamos viendo en la
calle es la realidad
y ahora voy con antonella martí y
antonella ya para darle cierre por el
momento a este tema de la discusión
racial tan fuerte en este momento en
eeuu en la convención en estos últimos
días o los primeros tres que ya pasaron
han sido muy enfáticos los oradores en
asegurar que los republicanos no son
racistas que esa es una idea que los
demócratas han intentado meter en la
cabeza de la ciudadanía para alterar la
decisión del voto el próximo 3 de
noviembre así que pues yo quisiera
pedirle que nos aclare esta idea cómo es
percibido el racismo en eeuu y si
realmente hay ánimos racistas en alguno
de los partidos o si están haciendo un
mal uso de una estrategia política con
un tema tan delicado como es la igualdad
de derechos de sus ciudadanos
mira yo creo que efectivamente esto es
algo que está sucediendo o una realidad
que no se puede negar algo que también
lo vemos dentro de ciertos sectores del
partido republicano creo que esto
también ya que tocamos una cuestión que
enmarca al racismo creo que también la
situación de la inmigración es algo
importante también para mencionar hemos
escuchado cientos de veces al presidente
donald trump hablar de una manera o
referirse de una manera despectiva hacia
los inmigrantes no los recuerdo uno de
los de los discursos en los que se
refiere a los mexicanos diciendo que
méxico no manda a gente como los que
estaban en esa audiencia presentes sino
que manda a los peores y yo creo que
estas cosas nos tienen que dejar un
mensaje claro no verdaderamente ante el
problema que se está enfrentando en este
momento los eeuu en términos de
nacionalismos en términos que creo que
también abarcan mucho a una coyuntura
bastante global y me atrevería a decir
iberoamericana este surgimiento de
pulimos tanto de derecha como de
izquierda y creo que el presidente
donald trump y el candidato joe biden
hoy nos muestran señales claras de estos
auge de los populismos vuelvo a insistir
tanto de derechas como de izquierdas a
lo largo del mundo el resurgir del
nacionalismo al resurgir del
proteccionismo comercial el resurgir de
esta falta de respeto hacia las
libertades individuales económicas y
políticas creo que es algo muy claro que
durante esta administración la
administración también anterior
se ha llevado digamos avasallado de una
manera muy clara a la separación o la
división de los poderes no esta idea de
el estado de derecho o el de los bloques
la base que constituye a los a los eeuu
y como siempre decimos eeuu es un país
maravilloso un país que se forja y nace
precisamente en base a los principios
liberales a los principios de los padres
fundadores que creen en el libre mercado
la libre competencia la libre empresa en
un tamaño pequeño del gobierno y además
en el control y los límites sobre todo
hacia la persona que gobierna el país
la concepción del estado de derecho del
bulo flow como bien mencionábamos recién
es algo que creo que a ninguno de los
dos candidatos que hoy se perfilan
parece gustarles por eso yo vuelvo a
insistir que hay que tener en cuenta a
los candidatos también que levantan la
voz porque no es solamente aove yo creo
que esto es algo que hay que hay que
definirlo el bipartidismo en eeuu es
algo muy arraigado y creo que hay que
romper un poco con esa con esa tradición
y dejar de elegir al mal menor y saber
que existen otras opciones y candidatos
que levantan la voz a favor de estas
libertades fundamentales
yo siempre mencionó la candidata del
partido libertario jørgensen porque creo
que es una persona también que nos
muestra y que tiene además un mensaje
muy claro sobre cuáles son los países
exitosos los modelos exitosos y las
políticas públicas exitosas a seguir
entonces creo que estos son sólo unos
temas que también tenemos que empezar a
definir y poner sobre la mesa entonces a
usted antonella y pasamos ahora a un
momento en el pasado
recordemos las declaraciones que dio el
día de hoy kamala harris fórmulas
vicepresidenciales de joe biden en el
partido demócrata
harris fue muy dura al afirmar que trump
falló como presidente
donald trump field donald con fracaso en
el trabajo más básico e importante de un
presidente de eeuu
efe jls chip exact no logró proteger al
pueblo estadounidense
simple y llanamente trump demostró lo
que nosotros en la profesión legal
llamaríamos un desprecio imprudente por
el bienestar del pueblo estadounidense
un desprecio imprudente de clases
descargar harris tampoco escatimó en sus
críticas al mandatario por su manejo de
la pandemia
recordemos que en un principio donald
trump minimizó la gravedad de la
epidemia de kobe 19 e incluso en algún
momento llegó a crear confusión diciendo
que para protegerse la gente debía
ingerir desinfectantes
y esto es lo que deben entender sobre la
naturaleza de una pandemia es implacable
no puedes detenerla con un tuit
y kate a distraer puedes crear una
distracción y esperar que desaparezca no
desaparecerá
by schneider por su naturaleza una
pandemia es implacable
si te equivocas desde el inicio las
consecuencias serán catastróficas y
también será muy difícil recuperarse en
este chat y aunque no tienes una segunda
oportunidad para hacerlo bien bueno el
presidente trump se equivocó desde el
principio
ricard font quien es bueno y en este
momento regreso con munilla
porque ni estábamos escuchando las
declaraciones de kamala harris y esto
nos hace también recordar como joe biden
en su intervención la semana pasada dijo
que él sí sabía cómo enfrentar una
pandemia que ya tenía la expertise
necesaria porque él tuvo que enfrentar
el ébola como vicepresidente de los eeuu
en el pasado y pues qué tan cierto es
esto porque la verdad es que él kobe 19
como sabemos es un virus que llega como
algo novedoso nuevo a la humanidad algo
que no sabemos manejar información es
que cambian todos los días y realmente
lo que hay es muchísima confusión
creo que es más fácil para hablar sobre
la pandemia desde fuera que para todos
los mandatarios del mundo que tienen a
su cargo el manejo de este virus tan
complicado y esta situación tan
complicada dicho esto creo que
siendo completamente objetiva la
capacidad de manejo de crisis y manejo
de situaciones de joe biden es superior
a la que ha demostrado donald trump que
ha tenido dificultades en el manejo de
las tres crisis que tiene en este
momento entonces y el hecho que hayan
justamente que yo vaya incluido a came
las aves no solamente en su equipo más
cercano sino como candidata a
vicepresidente la verdad dice mucho de
él porque si fueron unos ataques feroces
por parte de una fiscal en un debate si
bien fue era un momento político pues
fue algo que dolió el hecho de que él
pueda incluir en su equipo personas que
piensan distinto personas que son
capaces de enfrentarlo y criticar lo
dicen mucho de su capacidad de manejo de
crisis y de su capacidad de manejo del
país
gracias france24 está con ustedes desde
la semana pasada haciendo la cobertura
de uno de los momentos más importantes
de la campaña presidencial en eeuu la
semana pasada estuvimos hablando y
transmitiendo en directo también toda la
convención demócrata esta semana el
turno fue para la convención republicana
y hemos visto las voces no solamente de
los candidatos presidenciales y de sus
fórmulas vicepresidenciales sino también
es de las figuras más destacadas de los
dos partidos que predominan en los eeuu
continuamos con este análisis vamos a
estar aquí presentes esperando el
momento en el que se pronuncie donald
trump ver para el gran cierre o las
grandes sorpresas que el mismo
mandatario ha dicho que tenía preparadas
para esta noche en una convención que ha
sido parcialmente virtual parcialmente
presencial pero en la que el mandatario
ha insistido mucho en que se ha cuidado
de no tener muchas aglomeraciones para
proteger a los ciudadanos del cob y 19 y
regresó con más sobre cámara jarvis
porque es un personaje interesante que
surgió en las últimas semanas en la
carrera presidente
cuando fue elegida por joe biden y le
pregunto maría herrera porque kamala
harris se presenta como una figura
fuerte que podría eventualmente usted
medir a desestabilizar aún más está esta
carrera de donald trump a la casablanca
teniendo en cuenta que ha bajado su
popularidad en las encuestas
bueno yo realmente no estoy de acuerdo
yo no creo que la figura de kamala
harris afecta para nada la candidatura
del presidente es una mujer que ha sido
seleccionada por el hecho de ser mujer y
de color
en primer lugar típico del partido
demócrata no porque fuese la mejor
persona posicionada sino porque tienen
que rellenar unas cuotas escuchamos hace
dos semanas como ella misma reconocía
que los ataques a iovine eran parte de
un debate que no tenían nada que ver lo
que demuestra que no es una candidata
real nadie habrá algo que disculpar con
usted la voy a interrumpir un segundo ya
retomamos pero es que está hablando rudy
giuliani y vamos a escucharlo en directo
progresista demócrata como alcalde mayor
que fue descrita como la capital del
crimen se había convertido para los años
90 la ciudad grande más segura del país
ahora hoy mi ciudad está en shock
con crimen violento asesinatos y robos
están aumentando a unas tasas que no se
habían escuchado en el pasado vemos el
retorno de los saqueos y los disturbios
durante esos momentos este alcalde ha
evitado que la policía haga arrestos e
incluso cuando se hacen esos arrestos
los progresistas liberan a estos
saqueadores los neoyorquinos se
preguntan cómo nos abrumó el crimen de
manera tan rápida y subió tan rápido no
permitan que los demócratas le hagan
eeuu lo que le han hecho nueva york de
nuevo los demócratas les están pidiendo
que voten por un candidato defectuoso
spider ha cambiado sus principios tantas
veces que ya no tiene principio alguno y
es un caballo de troya con bernie con
ellos y con pelos y con black lips
matter y su país su partido está
completamente tirado a la izquierda para
ejecutar su agenda socialista y anti
policía
esta ola comienza con una causa justa el
imperdonable asesinato de georges boy de
minneapolis y las manifestaciones
pacíficas comenzaron en todo el país
la combinación del asesinato la condena
fue universal desde dentro hasta los
líderes demócratas parecía durante unos
pequeños momentos cortos que demócratas
y republicanos se iban a unir con una
propuesta unificada para reducir este
tipo de comportamientos por parte de la
policía esta posibilidad era muy
peligrosa para la izquierda tenían un
país que destruido
esta acción contra la policía sería muy
valiosa y haría que el presidente camps
se viera como un líder efectivo no
querían nada de eso entonces la clave es
matar y antifaz entraron en acción y de
manera rápida se tomaron estas protestas
y las convirtieron en disturbios
violentos pronto las manifestaciones se
convirtieron en motines y revueltas en
ciudades prácticamente lideradas todas
por demócratas las personas golpeadas
disparos oficiales de la policía
atacados y golpeados y a veces
asesinados y la policía se vio atada por
los alcaldes demócratas que simplemente
observaban los crímenes y recibíamos
golpes y peor con el asesinato de
personas inocentes que tenían toda su
vida por delante el asesinato de tal
afar de cuatro años en kansas chocó a
todo el país pero no habla clijsters me
asusté
seguidores demócratas brandon hendrix
igualmente fue asesinado en el bronx
días después de graduarse de la
secundaria y en camino a sam jones para
jugar básquetbol
falleció y apenas lo mencionaron un niño
de un año de boca juniors fue
asesinado en sus coches y eso no causó
ningún tipo de escándalo al presidente
camps y para nosotros republicanos todas
las vidas negras importan y las vidas de
grande branding y deseado importan para
nosotros todas importan estos disturbios
que continúan en las ciudades demócratas
dan una buena vista del futuro bajo una
administración byd en todas las top 5 de
ciudades para los robos y los saqueos
están gobernadas por demócratas
progresistas que están utilizando este
enfoque para el crimen que es
básicamente no hacer nada en lugar de
reducirlo liberar prisioneros tanto como
puedan y entrar en guerra con la policía
en un único grupo que tiene la capacidad
de proteger a nuestros ciudadanos
es claro que un voto por bardem y por
los demócratas crea el riesgo de que
ustedes traigan este tipo de
comportamientos a sus ciudades a sus
suburbios ya su pueblo
no hay duda de que este elemento trabajo
de restaurar la seguridad para el pueblo
no puede hacerse desde el sótano joe
entonces tampoco hay duda que el
presidente camps va a luchar con toda su
fuerza para preservar el sistema de
gobierno y nuestra manera de vida y en
momentos críticos de nuestra historia
eeuu siempre se ha visto bendecida con
la persona correcta para atender la
crisis washington lincoln roosevelt
reagan
fueron perfectos para los retos que
enfrentaron y llevaron a esta nación de
manera explore llosa el presidente camps
con su amor sin límites por el país y
por nuestro pueblo
su ética de trabajo disciplinada su
habilidad excepcional para inspirar y su
entendimiento del sistema de gobierno y
su respeto por los valores
estadounidenses es un hombre que podemos
confiar para mejorar nuestra manera de
vida señor presidente haga que nuestra
nación sea segura de nuevo
rudy giuliani ex alcalde de nueva york y
también abogado personal de donald trump
regresó con usted de maría herrera
estratega republicana que nos acompaña
desde la florida para que por favor
termine su idea estábamos hablando sobre
kamala harris y ya pasamos al siguiente
tema correcto bueno pues con respecto a
kamala harris como decíamos es una es
una antigua fiscal de la ciudad de san
francisco que sé que fue bastante
conocida por encarcelar a miles de
afroamericanos y de hispanos
tenía una postura bastante fuerte y
luego se fue un poquito dulcificando
desde luego es una persona que ha hecho
unos comentarios muy desafortunados como
por ejemplo comparar a las fuerzas de
inmigración de ais con el ku kux klan
también es una persona que no entiende
de la separación de poder esfuerzo que
en el tema principalmente del aborto
ella no ve las líneas que separan
la capacidad del gobierno federal de
limitar el aborto con respecto a los
estados defiende la agenda radical de
izquierda del partido demócrata este
partido demócrata quien no muchos no
reconocemos que abraza el socialismo que
proclama que va a levantar el embargo a
cuba el país más desestabilizador de
toda hispanoamérica y por no decir del
mundo y es una mujer que a mí no me
inspira para nada confianza yo creo que
las mujeres las mujeres hispanas tenemos
que pasar de todas esas esas cuotas y
todas estas digamos dulces que nos
ofrecen a la vista para fijarnos
realmente en los valores y los
principios de los candidatos y yo creo
que los hispanos somos conservadores
somos personas de principios y de
valores y que el derecho a la vida las
fronteras seguras y una prosperidad
económica es la mejor apuesta
para este país viene gracias por su
opinión y vamos en directo con el
senador tom cotton que a esta hora habla
es por eso que eeuu es más segura ahora
que hace cuatro años pero joe biden nos
regresaría a un camino peligroso
barack obama el propio secretario de
defensa de obama joe biden se ha
equivocado prácticamente en cada
decisión es de seguridad nacional mayor
de las últimas cuatro décadas
entonces comparemos los récords de baden
baden acabó con los gastos de defensa
los redujo el presidente reconstrucción
las fuerzas militares y le agregó la
fuerza espacial spider llevó a los
terroristas de isis a tomarse en medio
oriente mientras que el frob eliminó el
líder de isis y destruyó el califato joe
biden se opuso a la misión para matar a
osama bin laden el presidente camps
vengo la muerte de cientos de
estadounidenses matando más a la mente
criminal de iran qasem soleimani joe
biden envió dinero a los ayatolás
mientras el presidente camps acabó con
el peligroso acuerdo nuclear con irán
yo bailé entre todas israel como un no
como un amigos mientras que promovió la
embajada de jerusalén y creó acuerdos de
paz para medio oriente
joe biden se acercó a los dictadores de
cuba y venezuela- presidente camps lucha
en contra del comunismo en el patio de
estadounidenses y también en el mundo y
en el partido comunista de china no hay
comparación
joe biden ayudó al crecimiento de china
durante 50 años con acuerdos
comerciales que acabaron con el empleo
en eeuu mientras que jon se enfrenta al
robo y a las mentiras de chinchón job
aiden permitió el festival chino pasará
por la frontera sur mientras que trump
evitó que estas drogas envenenar a
nuestros hijos bailen dijo que estos
comunistas no son nuestros competidores
solamente meses antes de que liberaran
esta plaga para el mundo 28 tiene claro
cuál es la amenaza china y hace que
china vaya a pagar pero el chino no se
rinde de hecho están apoyando a byd en
los otros enemigos de eeuu tampoco se
van a rendir pero yo waiting sería débil
por los próximos 4 años como lo ha sido
en los últimos 50 necesitamos un
presidente que se levante por eeuu y no
uno que se arrodille
en eeuu orgulloso es un país seguro
seguro de la guerra y de nuestros
enemigos nadie que haya visto el rostro
de la guerra desea verlo de nuevo muchos
de nuestros compatriotas ya están
honrados en arlington
pero si queremos paso tenemos que ser
fuertes
la debilidad es provocada y provocadora
y el presidente camps y su fortaleza nos
ha alejado de la guerra
bailén no va a defender eeuu mientras
que trump si entonces en noviembre
quedémonos con el presidente y votemos
para mantener a eeuu grande
[Música]
estábamos escuchando al senador
republicano tom cotton quien ha tocado
un tema muy espinoso dentro de la
administración trump y es la relación
que se tiene con china para hablar sobre
este tema e invitó nuevamente a nuestra
corresponsal de ana castañeda desde
washington dc y diana yo le quiero pedir
que nos dé por favor el panorama sobre
esta relación tan difícil
si realmente será un reto para el
presidente de donald trump si llega a
ser reelegido pero también en el caso de
yo bailé debido a lo que vimos durante
estos últimos años empezando por esta
guerra comercial de sanciones donde una
de las prioridades del presidente de un
acromo de los argumentos frente a estas
medidas era que china no respetaba los
derechos de propiedad intelectual
discúlpeme la tengo que interrumpir
nuevamente estamos esperando algunas
intervenciones y en este momento hablan
karl y marcia müller que son los padres
de una mujer estadounidense que falleció
asesinada por el estado islámico en 2013
le pidieron que cruzara la frontera
siria para trabajar en un hospital el 4
de agosto de 2013
los terroristas de isis detuvieron su
vehículo y se la llevaron
estuvo encerrada en un lugar sucio y
frío los terroristas de isis le
apuntaron la raparon la cabeza la
torturaron el líder de isis abu bakr al
bagdadí la violó de manera repetida
durante 18 meses ella tuvo que soportar
esto y nosotros
y tratamos de trabajar con la
administración de obama y confiamos en
el gobierno pero el gobierno nos falló
el presidente obama se rehusó a reunirse
con nosotros hasta que isis ya había
decapitado a otros estadounidenses hasta
este día nunca hemos escuchado nada de
joe biden la administración de obama se
había escondido detrás de las políticas
tanto que nos sentimos desesperanzados
cuando evitaron que negociaremos para
salvar la vida de keith la la
administración mostró más preocupación
por los terroristas de guantánamo que
por los rehenes estadounidenses en siria
se preparó una misión de rescate pero la
casa blanca la retrasó y cuando
avanzaron con ella ella ya había sido
movida a otra ubicación y después de 18
meses de tortura aprendimos por parte de
isis que que la había sido asesinada la
administración de obama nos decía que
estaban haciendo todo lo que podían pero
su versión de las cosas no fue
suficiente qué diferencia hace un
presidente bajo el presidente champ
lazos se llevaron a cabo ataques
en el campo de al bagdadí cuando
aprendimos que la verdad fue asesinado
aprendimos que estas personas
se empeoraron la se nombraron como la
operación
8 14 por las cifras de el cumpleaños de
caída y a esos soldados queremos
agradecerles que ya nos estaban mirando
aquel día el equipo de chip nos dio la
empatía que nunca recibimos por parte de
la administración de obama la
administración obama dijo que estamos
haciendo todo lo que podía pero la
administración trump si lo hace déjeme
decir algo que ya debería estar aquí si
trump fue hubiese sido presidente cuando
la capturaron ella estaría aquí el día
de hoy cuando keith la fue tomada como
rehén yo iba al patio mirar a la luna y
miraba esa luna y le prometía que haría
todo lo que podía para traerla a casa
ahora cuando veo la luna me recuerdo de
mi promesa una promesa que no pude
cumplir
todo lo que quería era regresar a casa
con la ayuda de dios pensábamos que
podíamos traer la casa que ya era un
milagro y pensamos que nunca tendríamos
un segundo hijo pero tuvimos a kinder y
ella se dio a sí misma al mundo ocho
meses después de un cautiverio de que
jdd a otro rehén pudo sacar una carta
que ella había escrito cuando la leímos
podríamos ver que dios la estaba
manteniendo en sus brazos y en sus
palabras ella se sentía atendida y
también escribió me han mostrado la luz
en la oscuridad y he aprendido que
incluso en la prisión uno puede ser
libre me siento agradecida he tenido
muchas horas para pensar como solamente
en su ausencia solamente los 25 años
pude darme cuenta cuál es su lugar en mi
vida
ninguno de nosotros pudo pensar que esto
sería tan largo pero también estoy
luchando
y aún tengo mucho por dar dentro de mí
no me estoy dejando derribar y no me voy
a rendir no importa cuánto dure esto
keyla me enseñó tantas cosas como su
madre ella aún nos enseña muchas cosas
caudillo apoyamos a donald trump por su
compromiso para mantener a eeuu grande
no con el poder del gobierno sino con la
pasión de las personas como keila
estadounidenses que incluso en los días
más oscuros siempre tienen más lucha por
entregar estadounidenses que no
solamente hablan sino que actúan esa era
nuestra hija ese es también el
presidente mientras que nos mantengamos
fuertes como keila mientras que nos
rehusamos a rompernos seremos grandes
muchas gracias
[Música]
las 24 transmite para ustedes en directo
y también analiza el último día de la
convención nacional republicana en los
eeuu recordemos además que ya faltan un
poco más de dos meses para las
elecciones presidenciales en el país
unas elecciones que están marcadas por
la pandemia del coi 19 y que han llevado
a una campaña muy atípica y en eso se
enmarca esta convención que se ha
realizado en parte de manera virtual y
también con las conglomeraciones que son
muchísimo menores a las que vemos
acostumbradamente cada cuatro años
cuando se preparan los candidatos de los
dos partidos predominantes en eeuu esta
noche
donald trump se prepara para teclear a
su rival demócrata joe biden frente a
sus interlocutores en el jardín sur de
la casa blanca mientras que el país
sigue luchando contra la pandemia de
coronavirus y contra una ola de
manifestaciones contra el racismo
lideradas por los activistas del
movimiento las vidas negras
hay varios extractos que ya se conocen
sobre el discurso que iba a pronunciar
donald trump en unos minutos
donald trump debe enfatizar mucho en que
hace cuatro años prometió que sería la
voz y la promesa para los eeuu y que aún
tiene muchísimo más por hacer por el
país
vamos a continuar entonces con este
análisis que venimos desarrollando aquí
en france24
tuvimos que interrumpir hace unos
minutos a nuestra corresponsal en
washington adel diana castañeda y diana
regresó con usted sabiendo tanto para
ustedes como para mamani nuestras tres
analistas de esta noche que en cualquier
momento debo interrumpir las cuando
sigan saliendo los oradores clave a dar
sus declaraciones
en la convención entonces diana le
estaba preguntando por la problemática
relación que ha tenido en el trompo con
china
si no solamente desde el punto de vista
comercial cuando decimos digamos este
intercambio de sanciones en materia de
aranceles porque la justificación de la
casa blanca
la razón que argumentaba el presidente
de unalt unam es que china no estaba
respetando los derechos de propiedad
intelectual de muchas compañías en los
eeuu y a esto después se le sumó
recientemente el manejo que china le
había dado al tema de la pandemia al
inicio y también la colaboración que el
presidente argumentaba tenía con la
organización mundial de la salud y desde
entonces vimos cómo el presidente de
donald trump comenzó a llamar a el
coronavirus el virus chino y también
como se ha repetido digamos esta
expresión durante toda la convención
incluso por parte de su hijo y
recientemente se le sumó también estos
incidentes según agencias de seguridad
de los eeuu y del departamento de estado
que aseguraban que algunos funcionarios
diplomáticos chinos en los eeuu estaban
realizando labores de espionaje
así que hacen una relación muy difícil
el gobierno chino y el presidente de
donald trump y definitivamente será un
reto para cualquiera de los dos ya sea
para bailén o restablecer digamos
relaciones o mejorar estas relaciones
que han estado desgastadas durante esta
administración y en el caso de donald
trump también sería una tensa relación
entre las dos naciones y llega a ser
reelegido y continúa en la casablanca en
bueno diana y hace unos minutos cuando
la interrumpí estábamos escuchando a
carly y marcia müller que eran los papás
de esta trabajadora que fue asesinada y
abusada por el estado islámico y esto
solamente para pedirle que también nos
hable acerca de la política de seguridad
que ha tenido donald trump durante estos
cuatro años de mandato y sobre la
insistente declaración de los
republicanos que dicen que con joe biden
el país no va a estar seguro lo dijo
ayer muchísimas veces mike pence
y efectivamente el presidente de donald
trump durante toda la convención ha
tratado de mostrarse como el único líder
que puede restaurar la ley y el orden y
también mantener el liderazgo de los
eeuu a nivel global y esto estaba
enmarcado no solamente en la promesa de
luchar para destruir al estado islámico
y a sus principales líderes y veíamos
como esta historia pues trataba de
reforzar este está narrativa que está
dando ahora el partido republicano en la
convención mostrando como esta joven que
realizaba labores humanitarias
fue secuestrada por esta organización
terrorista en alepo
fue mantuvo digamos cautiva por cerca de
17 meses y los padres intentaron en
varias ocasiones comunicarse con el
presidente obama para tratar de que se
diera algún tipo de rescate pero esto
pues no ocurrió
simplemente fue confirmado por el
gobierno en los eeuu la muerte cuando
los padres recibieron fotografías que
les envió el estado islámico a su correo
personal así que esto muestra digamos el
disgusto de fuerza está digamos mensajes
que quiere enviar el partido republicano
de que el presidente cuando se preocupa
por cada uno de sus ciudadanos pero
también es un mensaje como comentaba
anteriormente que veremos durante toda
esta noche hasta el final de la
convención de liderazgo que debe tener
eeuu y que lo ha mostrado digamos desde
la perspectiva republicana en la labor
que ha jugado frente a este conflicto
entre israel y palestina frente a corea
del norte frente también a países que
significan un riesgo para la estabilidad
global como son irán la promesa de una
acción de retirar las tropas de
afganistán así que veremos como van
toda la noche y el presidente lo va a
explicar de manera más amplia lo que
considera sus logros en materia de
seguridad y de política exterior gracias
diana por su intervención y vamos a
hacer un repaso acerca de los temas que
esperamos que esta noche toque el
presidente donald trump y que va a
profundizar mucho más en las próximas
semanas en lo que le queda de campañas
para poder quedarse en la casa blanca-
donald trump poder nos hablará acerca de
la importancia de erradicar el kobe 19
acerca de la confianza y los conflictos
que existen con china también se espera
que hable del tema de la salud y de
educación asimismo vamos a ver cómo va a
hablar de los límites del mandato del
del congreso y lo que él llama poner fin
al acoso del gobierno burocrático de
ciudadanos estadounidenses y de pequeñas
empresas también de defender a la
policía y esto sobre la polémica que
existe porque los demócratas han
impulsado un llamado a que se desmantele
completamente la policía los
desheredados republicanos insisten
también en que él no debe desmantelarse
sino que debe
reformarse porque deben arreglarse los
problemas judiciales que existen y
también una de las banderas de donald
trump desde hace cuatro años que es
terminar con la inmigración ilegal y
proteger a los trabajadores de los eeuu
hablará también acerca de innovación y
de eeuu que desea él sea la primera en
política exterior
donald trump ha dicho que todavía tiene
mucho más que hacer que esta elección es
clara y que los estadounidenses tienen
la oportunidad para elegir entre dos
posturas que difieren muy claramente que
son completamente opuestas y bueno esto
se puede ver en la polarización que
existe en este momento en el país dice
donald trump que es ir hacia adelante en
la libertad personal o hacia atrás en el
mayor control del gobierno y bueno dicho
esto me invitó nuevamente a nuestra
corresponsal desde nueva york de mamen
sala para conversar mamen con ustedes
acerca de esta polémica que existe sobre
si se debe o no desmantelar la policía
usted está en una de las ciudades más
del país donde se ven diariamente
muchísimos conflictos con la policía de
nueva york así que que nos podría decir
basada en todo lo que nos ha reportado
durante estos últimos cuatro años
sí de hecho creo que él es alcalde de
nueva york rudy giuliani ha actualizado
el ejemplo porque aquí sin duda es donde
más estamos viendo a ese
desmantelamiento o no de la policía
porque pues bueno porque nueva york como
él decía efectivamente durante su
mandato el índice de criminalidad bajó
pero desgraciadamente a raíz de los
hechos que hemos visto de esas protestas
de esas vandalismos que vimos durante
este verano en las calles por las
protestas por la muerte de georg floyd
poco a poco se fueron recortando
presupuestos dentro de la policía de
hecho el último fue de un 16 por ciento
de los 6 mil millones de dólares que se
destina a este cuerpo y esto que ada que
ha dado lugar pues bien a que muchos
agentes y así lo han expresado tengan
miedo a salir a la calle y hacer su
trabajo muchos de ellos se han cogido
pues una baja por enfermedad o por
ansiedad en fin a excusas varias que han
hecho que al final la ciudad esté vacía
de policías y esto está dando lugar a
que efectivamente se estén alcanzando
unos niveles de criminalidad que no se
veían desde
90 de hecho se ve mucha menos presencia
de los agentes de la policía y las
cifras cada vez suben cada vez sufren
más suben más
mientras tanto donald trump defiende
pues como tú decías no no desmantelarla
sino reorganizar la y para ello pues 11
de sus de sus puntos en la agenda es
invertir más dinero en el cuerpo de la
policía
el llevar también ante la justicia a los
grupos extremistas antifascistas y en
definitiva darles más herramientas para
que ellos lleven a cabo su trabajo ese
trabajo de ley y orden como él dice
gracias mamen y vamos en este momento
con la hija de donald trump e ivanka
trump a hablar
nuestros corazones están con ustedes el
presidente va a continuar apoyándolos en
cada paso del camino y como siempre
hacemos los estadounidenses la nación se
unirá para ayudarles a reconstruir sus
hogares sus negocios y sus comunidades
para que sean más fuertes y más
resilientes que nunca antes
hace cuatro años yo les presenté a un
constructor a un empresario a un
outsider y al nominado del pueblo el
precio para presidente de los eeuu esta
noche estoy aquí ante ustedes como la
hija orgullosa de el presidente del
pueblo
es nuestro comandante en jefe
el defensor del trabajador
estadounidense defensor del sentido
común y la voz de los hombres y mujeres
olvidados del país el presidente y mi
padre donald trump
[Aplausos]
esta noche quiero decirles y contarles
de el líder que yo conozco y lo que yo
quisiera que todos pudieran ver quiero
contarles la historia de un presidente
que está luchando por ustedes desde el
amanecer hasta el anochecer cuando se
han ido las cámaras se apagan los
micrófonos y las decisiones realmente
cuentan cuando el javits y yo nos fuimos
a vivir con nuestros hijos a washington
no sabíamos que nos enfrentábamos pero
nuestros hijos les encantó desde el
principio mi hijo joseph
les dio una réplica en lego de la casa
blanca el presidente aún la muestra en
la oficina oval justo ahí para que pueda
mostrarle a los líderes mundiales que
tiene los mejores nietos del mundo y
estoy de acuerdo
en los últimos cuatro años hemos
aprendido mucho he visto que en
washington es fácil que los políticos
puedan sobrevivir porque evitan las
peleas duras no podía creer que tantos
políticos realmente prefieren quejarse
de un problema en lugar de arreglarlo
quedé en shock al ver que la gente
dejaba los retos sin cumplir para poder
atacar al otro lado y poder hablar del
mismo tema en la próxima elección pero
yo no vino a washington para hacer lo
mismo el vino a washington por una sola
razón hacer a eeuu grande de nuevo
[Aplausos]
mi padre tiene convicciones fuertes él
sabe en que cree y dice lo que piensa ya
sea que estén de acuerdo con él o no
siempre saben en donde se ubica
reconozco que el estilo de comunicación
de mi padre no es para el gusto de todos
y sé que sus tweets pueden ser un poco
sin filtro pero los resultados son los
que hablan por sí mismos
[Aplausos]
respecto a lo que cree y ha hecho que
tanto yo como tantos estadounidenses
miremos nuestras propias convicciones y
nos preguntemos qué es lo que defendemos
qué tipo de eeuu queremos dejar a
nuestros hijos yo estoy más segura que
nunca antes que queremos un futuro donde
nuestros hijos puedan creer en la
grandeza estadounidense queremos en la
sociedad donde cada niño pueda vivir en
una comunidad segura e ir a una gran
escuela de su elección
queremos una cultura donde las
diferencias de opinión y el debate sean
alentados y no cancelados donde las
autoridades sean respetadas donde la
diversidad sea celebrada y dónde
la gente desde cualquier origen o credo
pueda alcanzar su potencial dado por
dios este es el futuro que mi padre
trabaja por construir todos los días
[Aplausos]
construir después de todo es lo que ha
hecho toda su vida es admirado
y ha trabajado en cientos de
construcciones pero ha sido una profunda
experiencia para ella para mí ver a los
trabajadores venir hacia él con una
lágrima en los ojos y agradecerle por
ser la única persona en defenderlos por
su familia por sus hijos y su futuro a
los hombres y mujeres trabajadores del
país aquí esta noche ustedes son la
razón por la cual mi padre lucha con
todo su poder usted es una razón por la
cual se lanzó a la presidencia y ustedes
son la razón por la cual va a seguir
luchando por otros cuatro años
cómo
yo recuerdo una tarde en febrero de 2018
estábamos en la oficina oval con el
asesor económico de mi padre y el
presidente quería mantener su promesa de
renegociar los acuerdos comerciales que
habían acabado con miles de empleos de
la clase media la mayoría de los
asesores dijeron que la economía estaba
tan fuerte después de los cortes a las
regulaciones de los impuestos que no
tenía sentido hacerlo después de la
reunión cuando hablé con mi padre y lo
llevé a la residencia él me dijo la
razón por la cual esto no se ha hecho es
porque nuestros líderes no han tenido
las agallas cuando la economía estaba
bien se contentan con eso y no tienen y
siguen dejándolo para el futuro para que
sea problema de alguien más y estaba en
lo correcto si mi padre no hubiese
tomado estas peleas nadie lo habría
hecho en los meses que sirvieron el
presidente camps se rehusó
y quedarse con un buen trato quería un
gran trato y eso es exactamente lo que
obtuvimos
recuerdo cada vez que hablaban de los
progresos del acuerdo con méxico y
canadá decía
no dejes caer a estos campesinos que
conocí en wisconsin quiero que ellos
amen este nuevo acuerdo
hoy
en medio
de esta pandemia sin precedentes es más
claro que nunca que nuestro presidente
hizo lo correcto al tratar el tema del
comercio arreglando
y trayendo de nuevo los empleos y las
fábricas al país
[Aplausos]
mientras nuestro país se enfrenta a este
gran reto oro por las familias que han
perdido un ser querido por aquellos que
siguen luchando contra el kobe 19 y por
los trabajadores y los trabajadores de
salud que siguen en primera línea de
esta lucha el dolor y la pena la
ansiedad durante todo este tiempo es
sentida por todos he estado con mi padre
y he visto el dolor en sus ojos cuando
recibe las actualizaciones de las vidas
que se ha llevado este virus
he visto como tomadas las decisiones más
difíciles de su vida me senté con él en
la oficina oval cuando dejó cuando acabo
con él detuvo el viaje de los viajes de
europa y acabó y tuvo que dar marcha
atrás con la economía que iba
extremadamente bien y tenía tasas de
desempleo muy bajas y tuvo que cerrarla
para salvar vidas estadounidenses
[Aplausos]
es por eso que nuestro presidente
movilizó la fuerza del gobierno y del
sector privado para producir
respiradores en cuestión de semanas para
crear el sistema de testeo más grande
del mundo y crear tratamientos y muy
pronto una vacuna mi padre no se siente
desalentado por estos pensadores la
palabra imposible simplemente lo va a
motivar él rechaza la noción de que los
más grandes logros de este país están
detrás de nosotros él cree que nada está
fuera de nuestro alcance así que lo
mejor aún está por venir
[Aplausos]
sin he visto toda mi vida como mi padre
cree en el potencial de cada individuo
más temprano y todos nos vimos
inspirados por los el testimonio de la
lección son una hoguera que puede
sentenciada a la vida en prisión por un
crimen relacionado con drogas y yo
estaba ahí cuando mi padre decidió
comentar su sentencia juntos vimos a lee
salir de prisión después de cerca de 22
años y cuando fue a abrazar a su familia
y celebraron esa reunión
mi padre se quedó callado yo podía ver
la emoción en su rostro después de un
largo silencio me dijo imagina cuántas
personas están justo en la misma
situación que alex en ese momento se
convirtió en una voz para aquellos que
han sido silenciados de manera injusta
en el sistema de prisiones y el
rectificó
la ley creada por baile en el 94 que
afectó principalmente a los
afroamericanos
[Aplausos]
en contra de todas las apuestas el unido
a republicanos y demócratas para aprobar
la mayor reforma del sistema de justicia
penal y apenas estamos empezando
mi padre no hizo una campaña con este
tema simplemente atacó esta injusticia
porque siente una gran compasión por
aquellos que han sido tratados de manera
injusta más que retórica tiene la
habilidad de construir consensos y
construir éxitos bipartidistas van a
acabar con las inequidades raciales del
país y nos llevarán a unirnos el
presidente camps está haciendo avanzar
los valores estadounidenses de trabajo y
familia
hace 4 años en cleveland yo dije que el
presidente camps iba a cumplir con las
mujeres trabajadoras el año pasado más
del 70% de todos los nuevos empleos
fueron para las mujeres
hace cuatro años les dije que mi padre
se iba a concentrar en hacer que el
cuidado infantil por asequible y en el
primer término de hecho aprobamos la
mayor financiación al cuidado infantil
ayudándole a miles de familias un gran
cuidado a un costo que pueden pagar como
parte de los recortes de impuestos en
2019 solamente nuestros créditos
fiscales viajaron 2000 dólares en los
bolsillos de 40.000 familias
estadounidenses
los políticos demócratas introdujeron un
plan para aumentar esos créditos de
impuestos pero cuando yo estaba luchando
para asegurar que esto se duplicará ni
un solo demócrata votó para aprobar esa
ley y lo hicimos de todas formas
hace cuatro años prometí que el
presidente champ iba a apoyar a las
madres en la fuerza laboral en su primer
año firmó en ley
el primer crédito fiscal para
que miles de estadounidenses tengan
acceso
a este beneficio hace cuatro años dije
que necesitábamos una economía que
permitiera que la gente se levantara de
nuevo durante los primeros tres años en
el cargo 72% de todos los nuevos empleos
fueron a estadounidenses que habían
estado por fuera de la fuerza laboral
[Aplausos]
hace cuatro años les dije que lucharía
con mi padre y cuatro años después aquí
estoy
muchos de los temas que mi padre ha
liderado ahora han sido temas
republicanos
mi padre escoge el sentido común donde
ellos escogen el partido mi padre escoge
al pueblo
desde el día en que tomó el juramento he
visto como mi padre se enfrenta a las
políticas fallada fallidas del pasado y
hacer lo que ningún otro líder ha hecho
recientemente tomó una acción dramática
para recortar los precios de los
medicamentos de prescripción a pesar de
las llamadas de los hijos de las
compañías farmacéuticas ahora cuando
vemos estos
estas propagandas pagadas por estas
empresas el sonríe y me dice mira
estamos haciendo algo bien si nos están
atacando de manera tan fuerte
de spring el presidente dijo que
los cultivos estaban siendo dañados
también por el virus y le pidió el
secretario para el dub para que
encontráramos estas vegetales carne y la
llevaremos a las familias más
necesitadas en cuestión de días le
hallamos el producto creamos un programa
que ahora ha entregado más de 100
millones de comidas y nos ha llevado a
las manos de familias estadounidenses
[Aplausos]
para proteger a los más vulnerables de
nosotros he trabajado junto al
presidente mientras que él ha afirmado
la ley nueve legislaciones para combatir
al tráfico humano
[Aplausos]
he estado al lado de mi padre
cuando ha recibido y se ha mantenido su
resolución y su determinación para
detener de una vez por todas las guerras
en el exterior
para cambiar el paradigma en medio
oriente tome un nuevo enfoque escuche a
líderes que por favor no moviera la
embajada de la llevar a jerusalén sin
embargo el cumplió con esa promesa y que
una promesa que no fue cumplida por
otros presidentes porque él sabía que
era lo correcto
[Aplausos]
desafiando todas las expectativas hace
sólo semanas volvió a escribir la
historia haciendo un acuerdo de paz en
medio oriente
el mayor avance en un cuarto de siglo
por primera vez en mucho tiempo tenemos
un presidente que ha mostrado la
hipocresía de washington y lo odiaron
por eso para para la gente que ayuda por
no ser te ataca por no ser
convencionales pero yo te respeto porque
eres real y efectivo
nuestro presidente se rehúsa a rendir
sus creencias para cumplir con las
élites políticas para mi padre ustedes
son la élite ustedes son las únicas
personas con la cual quiere ganarse unos
puntos si estos problemas fueran fáciles
de resolver otros presidentes los
hubiesen resuelto pero no se obtienen
resultados diferentes haciendo las cosas
de la misma manera
washington no ha cambiado a de nacho
donald jones ha cambiado a washington
[Aplausos]
eeuu no necesita otro vehículo vacío que
haga lo que pide a su partido ahora más
que nunca eeuu necesita otros cuatro
años de un guerrero en la casa blanca
[Aplausos]
esta noche no podría sentirme más
orgullosa de presentar a mi padre un
hombre que sé que fue hecho para este
momento una historia queridos
estadounidenses nuestra primera dama y
el presidente número 45 de los eeuu
donald jay chou
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la ley viene solo
ligeros
[Música]
mire
en dicho evento
[Música]
[Aplausos]
gracias muchas gracias
amigos delegados y distinguidos
invitados por favor estoy aquí ante
ustedes esta noche es honrado por su
apoyo orgulloso del progreso
extraordinario que hemos logrado en los
últimos cuatro años increíbles y lleno
de confianza en un futuro brillante que
construiremos para eeuu en los próximos
cuatro años
muy bien comenzamos a esta noche
nuestros pensamientos están con la gente
maravillosa que acaba de pasar y de
sentir la ira del huracán
laura estamos trabajando con los
oficiales locales y estatales en texas
louisiana arkansas y misisipí y no
estamos
dejando de lado ningún esfuerzo fue uno
de los órganos más fuertes en tocar
tierra en 150 años
los daños fueron mucho menor de los
esperados hace sólo 24 horas
y esto se debe al gran trabajo de firma
de las autoridades y de los estados de
manera individual a donde yo iré este
fin de semana para felicitarlos por ese
gran trabajo que realmente apreciamos
somos una gran familia nacional y
siempre vamos a proteger el amor y el
cuidado de unos por otros aquí esta
noche están las personas que han hecho
que este camino para mí haya sido
posible y han llenado mi vida con tanta
alegría por su gran servicio la nación y
por sus hijos quiero agradecer a nuestra
magnífica primera dama
y también quiero agradecer a mi
increíble hija ivanka por esta
presentación y a todos mis hijos iván
que por favor levante
a todos mis hijos y los amo más de lo
que las palabras pueden expresar sé que
mi hermano robert nos está mirando desde
el cielo en este momento fue un gran
hermano y estaba muy orgulloso del
trabajo que todos nosotros estamos
haciendo muchas gracias
te amamos roberts
apreciamos también mostramos nuestro
precio por un hombre que siempre ha
luchado
y se ha levantado por nuestros valores
un hombre de una fe profunda y de gran
convicción nuestro vicepresidente
michaels
[Aplausos]
está aquí con su querida esposa una
madre militar con intensas
[Aplausos]
esta noche con un corazón lleno de
optimismo y gratitud acepto esta
nominación para presidente de los eeuu
[Aplausos]
el partido republicano el partido de
abraham lincoln avanza unido determinado
y listo para dar la bienvenida
demócratas independientes y a cualquiera
que crea en la grandeza de eeuu y el
corazón recto del pueblo estadounidense
en un nuevo término como presidente
vamos a construir de nuevo la mejor
economía de la historia de manera rápida
regresando al empleo total al aumento de
los ingresos y a una prosperidad récord
vamos a defender a eeuu en contra de
todas las amenazas ya proteger a los
estadounidenses en contra de todos los
peligros vamos a liderar y llevar este
país a nuevas fronteras de ambiciones y
descubrimientos y vamos a analizar y
buscar nuevas alturas en los logros
nacionales vamos a tener una nueva fe en
nuestros valores nuevo orgullo en
nuestra historia y un nuevo espíritu de
unidad que solamente puede ser cumplido
a través del amor por nuestro gran país
[Aplausos]
porque comprendemos que eeuu no es un
lugar oscuro eeuu es la antorcha que
ilumina el mundo entero
reunidos aquí en nuestra majestuosa casa
blanca conocido en todo el mundo como la
casa del pueblo solamente podemos
maravillarnos por el milagro que es
nuestra gran historia estadounidense
este ha sido el hogar de grandes figuras
como teddy roosevelt
andrew jackson que unió los
estadounidenses con nuevas visiones de
un futuro brillante en estas paredes
también vivieron grandes generales
tenaces como
eisenhower que llegaron a nuestros
soldados por la causa de la libertad
desde estos lugares
thomas jefferson
[Música]
nos envían una expedición por el
continente en las profundidades de una
guerra civil se han gris el presidente
abraham lincoln
miro por estas mismas ventanas para
completar el del monumento a washington
y preguntarle a dios en su providencia y
pedirle que salvará nuestra nación
dos semanas después de harvard
winston churchill y justo adentro
pusieron a llevar a nuestro pueblo en un
curso hacia la victoria en la segunda
guerra mundial y en días recientes
nuestra nación y todo el planeta ha sido
golpeado
por un nuevo y poderoso enemigo
invisible como esos estadounidenses
valientes antes de nosotros nos estamos
enfrentando al reto estamos
cumpliendo con terapias que salvan vidas
y estamos y vamos a producir una vacuna
antes del final del año o incluso
posiblemente antes
vamos a derrotar al virus y las
pandemias y vamos a salir de ahí más
fuertes que nunca antes
[Aplausos]
las misiones pasadas fue una confianza
en el destino estadounidense y una fe
inquebrantable en el pueblo de este país
sabían que nuestro país está bendecido
por dios y tiene un propósito especial
en este mundo es esa convicción la que
ha inspirado la formación de nuestra
unión y de nuestra expansión la
abolición de la esclavitud la aprobación
de los derechos civiles el programa
espacial y el derrocamiento del fascismo
la tiranía y el comunismo este espíritu
estadounidense ha superado todo reto y
nos ha levantado a la cumbre de las
acciones humanas
y a pesar de toda esta grandeza está es
una nación donde lo que hemos logrado
ahora está en peligro
por esta es la elección más importante
en la historia de nuestro país
[Aplausos]
gracias en ningún otro momento los
votantes se han enfrentado una opción
más clara entre dos partidos entre dos
visiones dos filosofías o dos agendas
esta elección va a decidir si salvamos
el sueño americano o si permitimos que
una agenda socialista acabe con nuestro
querido destino
va a decidir si rápidamente podemos
crear nuevos empleos por millones o si
acabamos con nuestras industrias y
enviamos millones de estos empleos al
exterior como se ha hecho durante tantas
décadas de manera tontas
su voto va a decidir si protegemos a los
estadounidenses que respetan la ley o si
le damos un reino libre a la violencia y
a los anarquistas a los agitadores a los
criminales que amenazan a nuestros
ciudadanos en esta elección vamos a
decidir si vamos a defender la vida
estadounidense o si vamos a permitir que
un movimiento radical desmantele
totalmente este sueño y lo destruya
[Aplausos]
en la convención nacional demócrata joe
biden y su partido repitieron y
mostraron a este país como un lugar de
injusticia racial y económica así que
esta noche les hago una simple pregunta
cómo puede el partido demócrata liderar
nuestro país cuando pasa tanto tiempo
dañando este país
[Aplausos]
en la visión de la izquierda no ven a
estados unidos como la nación más
excepcional y libre y justa del mundo
sino que ven una nación debilitada que
debe ser castigada por sus pecados y
oponente dice que la redención solamente
puede venir dándole el poder a ellos
este es un himno que ha sido
representado por cada movimiento
represivo en la historia pero en este
país no miramos a los políticos no busco
nos buscamos a los políticos de carrera
buscando salvación de ovidio buscamos al
gobierno para que nuestras tauro ponemos
nuestra fe en dios todopoderoso
[Aplausos]
yo bailé no es un salvador de el alma
estadounidense es el destructor de los
trabajos estadounidenses y si se le da
la oportunidad será el destructor de la
grandeza estadounidense durante 47 años
joe biden tomó las donaciones de los
obreros les dio abrazos y besos
y les dijo que sentía su dolor y después
voló de regreso a washington y voto para
enviar nuestros trabajos a china y
muchas otras tierras distantes yo bailé
pasó toda su carrera
llevándose a sus sueños y también los
sueños de trabajadores estadounidenses
abriendo las fronteras y enviando a sus
hijos e hijas a luchar en guerras
extranjeras eternas que nunca terminaron
hace cuatro años me lancé a residencia
porque no podía ver esta tradición de
nuestro país por más tiempo
no podía sentarme y ver como los
políticos de carrera dejaban que otros
tomaron ventaja de nosotros en política
exterior y en defensa y en el comercio
nuestros socios de la otan como por
ejemplo estaban muy por detrás en sus
pagos en materia de defensa pero
bajo mi pedido
van a pagar 130 mil millones más cada
año
y esos 130.000 millones de dólares
finalmente aumentaron a 400 mil millones
por año y el secretario general
stoltenberg que lidera la otan se vio
sorprendido después de ver como por
tantos años esto ocurría y mismo el
presidente de chapí solo que ningún otro
fue capaz de hacer
la forma la jve cuando dejé mi vida
tradicional atrás así que era una vida
muy buena
no he hecho nada más que luchar por
ustedes
hice lo que nuestro establecimiento
político nunca espero y cambiar las las
reglas de washington cumplí con mi
promesa
[Aplausos]
juntos hemos acabado la clase política
de mi gente y están desesperados por
retomar el poder por cualquier medio
necesario y ustedes lo han visto
están enojados conmigo porque en lugar
de ponerlos a ellos de primero yo
simplemente dije eeuu primero
gracias después de tomar el cargo
llegamos a washington y su
establecimiento y nos retiramos de el té
pp que era un tratado comercial que
estaba acabando con los empleos
a proveer las los oleoductos de kingston
y acabé
con el acuerdo climático de parís que
era tan costoso y por primera vez logre
la independencia energética en el país
[Aplausos]
cortes a las regulaciones y a los
impuestos a una tasa y a una velocidad
que nunca antes se había visto en
cuestión de tres años construimos la
economía más fuerte en la historia del
mundo guasch los insiders de washington
me pidieron que no me enfrentara chino y
que bien que permitiremos que china
siguiera robando nuestros empleos
pero yo mantuve mi palabra al pueblo
estadounidense nos enfrentamos a china
con las acciones más audaces y robustas
en la historia estadounidense de lejos
6 el de huelva pero que sería imposible
es reemplazar el in hasta
pero de nuevo estaban equivocados este
año acabe con la pesadilla de nafta y
firme en nuevo pemex
el acuerdo con méxico y canadá
y ahora las compañías automotrices y
muchos otros están construyendo sus
empresas y plantas en estados unidos no
despidiendo a sus empleados y no nos
están desertando o yéndose a otros
países
[Aplausos]
tal vez en ninguna otra aérea los
intereses especiales trataron de
detenernos que mi política
debe estar en pro de
la inmigración
[Aplausos]
pero hoy las centros estadounidenses son
más seguras que nunca antes
acabamos con la posibilidad de atrapar
sal y liberarte nos enfrentamos a los
traficantes que atacaban a las mujeres y
niños
y hemos deportado a 20.000 miembros de
pandillas y 500.000
extranjeros ilegales criminales hemos
construido 300 millas del muro
fronterizo y estamos agregando 10 millas
cada semana el muro pronto estará
terminado y está funcionando más allá de
nuestras expectativas
[Aplausos]
tenemos aquí miembros de las fuerzas de
patrulla que están representando a
nuestros agentes de patrulla a nuestros
agentes fronterizos gracias por estar
aquí gracias por su trabajo valiente
en este país como ama a sus autoridades
y realmente es así nos amamos y los
respetamos
[Aplausos]
cuando me enteré que las autoridades de
tennessee habían despedido a miles de
trabajadores
habían reemplazado por trabajos o por
trabajadores más baratos ahora esos
trabajadores talentosos han sido
recontratados y están de nuevo
entregándole energía a kentucky
mississippi north caroline y virginia
tienen de regreso sus trabajos y muchos
están aquí esta noche por favor levanten
ya han pasado por mucho
el mes pasado me enfrenté a las
industrias farmacéuticas creen que eso
es fácil no lo es y firmé órdenes que
van a reducir los costos de sus
medicamentos por prescripción y le darán
a los pacientes críticamente enfermos
acceso a curas y aprobamos el
la ley del derecho a probar
[Aplausos]
también aprobamos la rendición de
cuentas para los asuntos de los
veteranos para proteger a nuestros
grandes veteranos
[Aplausos]
91% de ellos me aprueba la primera vez
que eso ha ocurrido al final de mi
primer mandato habremos aprobado más de
300 jueces federales incluyendo dos
grandes jueces para la corte suprema
[Aplausos]
y para traer la prosperidad a nuestras
ciudades deprimidas aprobamos una
reforma que elimina la reforma a la
justicia penal
creamos zonas de oportunidades y
financiamos a las universidades
históricamente afroamericanas y antes de
que llegara el virus de china producimos
los mejores cifras de empleo para los
hispanos afroamericanos y los asiáticos
que jamás hayan sido registradas en el
país
y lo digo de manera modesta que he hecho
más por la comunidad afroamericana que
ningún otro presidente desde abraham
lincoln nuestro primer presidente
republicano
[Aplausos]
y he hecho más en tres años por la
comunidad afroamericana que yo baiden ha
hecho por ellos en 47 años
[Aplausos]
y cuando me reelijan lo mejor aún está
por venir
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias
cuando tome el cargo en medio oriente
estaba en un caos absoluto y si estaba
creciendo irán estaba también
levantándose y la guerra en afganistán
no parecía tener fin yo me retiré del
terrible
acuerdo nuclear con irán
[Aplausos]
mantuve mi promesa reconociendo la
verdadera capital de israel y enviando
ahí
nuestra embajada a jerusalén
[Aplausos]
pero no solamente hablamos como esto de
algo futuro sino que lo construimos en
lugar de pasar de gastar mil millones de
dólares en un nuevo edificio como
planeado tomamos ya un edificio
existente en una mejor ubicación es un
trato inmobiliario al fin y al cabo y lo
abrimos por un costo de menos de 500 mil
dólares
[Aplausos]
y también reconocimos la soberanía de
israel sobre los altos del golán y este
mes
logramos el primer puente acuerdo de paz
en 25 años
[Música]
gracias a israel y gracias a los
emiratos árabes unidos
[Aplausos]
y además acabamos con 100% del califato
de isis y matamos a su fundador y líder
abu bakr al bagdadí
[Aplausos]
la operación será eliminada terminamos
el terrorista número uno del mundo qasem
soleimani
[Aplausos]
a diferencia de otras administraciones
yo he mantenido a eeuu
lejos de nuevas guerras y nuestras
tropas están regresando a casa
hemos estado cerca de 2.5 billones de
dólares para reconstruir de manera total
nuestras fuerzas militares que estaba
fuertemente debilitada cuando yo llegué
al cargo
esto incluye aumentos salariales para
nuestros grandes guerreros
también lanzamos la fuerza espacial
la primera nueva rama desde que se creó
la fuerza aérea hacia hace casi 75 años
hemos pasado los últimos cuatro años
echando para atrás los daños que yo
bailén ha creado durante los últimos 47
el récord de bailén es una vergüenza y
un recuerdo de las peores tradiciones de
nuestra vida
él ha pasado toda su carrera del lado
incorrecto de la historia votó por el
desastre de nafta el peor acuerdo
comercial que jamás se haya aplicado
apoyó la entrada de china a la
organización mundial del comercio uno de
los mayores desastres de todos los
tiempos y después de esas calamidades de
paquete en eeuu perdió uno de cada
cuatro trabajos de manufactura ustedes
pidieron personas de michigan
pensilvania
y en muchos otros estados
y no querían escuchar las palabras
vacías de baile de empatía simplemente
querían que volvieran sus empleos
como vicepresidente el apoyo al pp que
hubiese sido una sentencia de muerte
para la industria automotriz nacional y
apoyó el terrible acuerdo comercial con
corea del sur que se llevó muchos
empleos de nuestro país y que yo también
acabé creando un nuevo acuerdo para el
país apoyó la amnistía masiva para los
ilegales voto a favor de la guerra en
irak
opuso a la misión para acabar con osama
bin laden se opuso a meter a
y apoyo el crecimiento de china como un
como algo positivo para ti y para eeuu
se parece un dos por eso que china apoya
a joe biden y desesperadamente quieren
que gane y puedo decirles eso basado en
información muy correcta bueno china
sería dueño de nuestro país si joe biden
es electo a diferencia de bailén
yo les haré rendir cuentas por la
tragedia que ellos han causado en todo
el mundo en meses recientes la nación y
el planeta han sido golpeados por una
pandemia de una vez en un siglo algo que
china permitió que se expandiera por
todo el planeta pudieron haberlo
detenido pero permitieron que saliera
estamos agradecidos
con los trabajadores de primera línea
los médicos y enfermeras por favor
levántense y acepten nuestra gratitud
media markt muchos estadounidenses
incluyéndome hemos partido amigos y
seres queridos con esta enfermedad
horrible como una nación sentimos el
dolor y la pena y llevamos en nuestros
corazones las memorias de todas esas
vidas que han sido perdidas y se han
llevado de manera trágica en su honor
nos vamos a unir y en su memoria vamos a
superar y cuando el virus chino golpeó
lanzamos la mayor movilización desde la
segunda guerra mundial invocando el
defense production act producimos la
mayor cantidad de respiradores ni un
solo estadounidense que alguna vez
necesita un respirador se le negó lo
cual es un milagro
gran trabajo ayudando esa fuerza de
trabajo por parte de nuestro gran
vicepresidente michaels
[Aplausos]
digamos millones de máscaras y guantes y
equipo de protección a nuestros
trabajadores para proteger a estas
personas estamos dando kits de prueba y
también a los hogares para la tercera
edad les damos todo lo que han
necesitado porque estamos cuidando de
las personas de la tercera edad
[Aplausos]
el equipo de ingenieros construyó
hospitales y también creamos hospitales
en barcos creamos desde cero el mayor
sistema de pruebas del mundo
y eeuu ha hecho más pruebas que todos
los países de europa combinados y más
que ningún otro país del hemisferio
occidental piensa en eso hemos llevado a
cabo 40 millones de pruebas más que si
creamos tratamientos incluyendo el
plasma compareciente vimos eso el
domingo en la noche cuando anunciamos
que esto va a salvar miles y miles de
vidas hemos sido pioneros
y vemos las cifras digamos que esa tasa
de mortalidad se ha reducido en un 80
por ciento desde abril
[Aplausos]
eeuu está
entre los países con menor cantidad
en europa de cerca de tres veces más
grande que la nuestra pero ellos aquí no
escriben y reportan eso no quieren que
ustedes sea para eso las naciones de
europa han experimentado un aumento en
la mortalidad en exceso más que en eeuu
hemos aprobado el mayor paquete de
alivio en la historia del país gracias a
nuestro paquete de protección de cheques
hemos también apoyado más de 50 millones
de empleos estadounidenses y es una de
las razones por las cuales estamos
avanzando de manera tan rápida
con la economía como resultado estamos
creciendo en la menor contracción de
cualquier nación occidental y estamos
recuperándonos a una tasa mucho más
rápida en los últimos tres meses hemos
tomado nuevos millones de empleos y ese
es un récord en la historia nacional
[Aplausos]
desafortunadamente desde el principio
nuestros oponentes se han mostrado
capaces de nada más que una habilidad
partidista para criticar cuando yo tomé
una acción audaz para imponer una
prohibición de viajes a china de manera
temprana joe biden se puso histérico y
dijo que era algo histérico en la
calificó de xenofóbica y también hicimos
lo mismo con europa de manera temprana
si hubiésemos escuchado a young miles de
estadounidenses habrían muerto y en
lugar de seguir la ciencia yo vaivén
quiere crear un nuevo cierre para todo
el país un nuevo cierre generaría un
daño irreparable para los niños parte de
familias y para los ciudadanos de todos
los orígenes el costo de un cierre de
bailín sería medido en las sobredosis en
las depresiones en las adicciones al
alcohol en los suicidios
los ataques al corazón la devastación
económica la pérdida de empleos y mucho
más
el plan de joe biden no es una solución
al virus sino más bien una rendición
ante el virus
mi administración tiene un enfoque muy
distinto a salvar cuantas vidas sean
posibles y para eso estamos apoyándonos
en los datos y en las ciencias
estamos de manera estamos protegiendo
las personas en riesgo particularmente a
las personas de la tercera edad mientras
que permitimos que quienes no están en
riesgo puedan regresar de manera segura
al trabajo y a la escuela y queremos ver
a tantas de esos estados y queremos que
estén abiertos tienen que volver al
trabajo
[Aplausos]
tiene que volver a trabajar y también
las escuelas lo más importante también
estamos trabajando con los genios
científicos para producir una vacuna en
tiempo récord bajo la operación work
speech vemos tenemos 13 vacunas en la
última fase de pruebas
y años por delante de lo que ha sido
logrado antes nadie jamás pensó que se
pudiera hacer de manera tan rápida si
alguien se hace normalmente en años pero
lo hicimos en meses y estamos creando
estos avances para que millones de dosis
sean disponibles de manera rápida
tendremos una vacuna segura este año y
juntos vamos a aplastar el virus
en la convención demócrata apenas
ustedes escucharon una palabra sobre su
agenda pero eso no es porque no tengan
una sino porque su agenda que se las son
las propuestas más extremas que jamás se
han adelantado por parte de un nominado
de un gran partido yo vaivén dice que es
un aliado de la luz pero cuando se trata
de su agenda bailén quiere mantenernos
absolutamente en la oscuridad no
entiende nada él ha prometido un aumento
de 4 billones de dólares en impuestos
para las familias que haría colapsar
nuestra economía que se está recuperando
rápidamente y también los mercados de
valores que ahora están en situación
récord también colapsaría
han pensado en todas las acciones que
tienen y como dicen mi primer término
voy a recortar aún más los impuestos
para las madres trabajadoras y los
padres no voy a aumentar impuestos los
voy a reducir de manera sustancial
y también vamos a ofrecer créditos
fiscales para que regresen los empleos
de china a eeuu e impondremos castigos
para las empresas que se lleven los
empleos fuera de la nación vamos a
asegurarnos que las compañías y los
trabajos se queden en este país como ya
lo he estado haciendo desde hace ya
bastante tiempo si se han dado cuenta la
agenda de joe biden
es hecho en china mi agenda es hecho en
eeuu
[Aplausos]
pueden ha prometido acabar con la
producción de petróleo de carbón y de
gas natural
acabando con las economías de
pensilvania ohio texas dakota del norte
oklahoma colorado y nuevo méxico va a
destruir esos estados totalmente así
como otros millones de empleos se
perderán y los precios de la energía van
a aumentar esas mismas políticas
llevaron a los cortes de electricidad
apenas en california la semana pasada a
todo el mundo lo vio
nadie ha visto algo como esto vimos esto
la semana pasada en california como
puede
iovine decir que es un aliado de la luz
cuando su propio partido ni siquiera
puede mantener las luces encendidas
no olvides que esta campaña de bailén
incluso ha publicado en una plataforma
de 110 páginas que también ha sido
descrita por el senador el 'loco' bernie
sanders el manifiesto de bardem y berni
quiere
suspender la remoción de ilegales
reinstaurar catch and release y darle
a estos criminales y esos ilegales
abogados para todos eso es lo que
necesitamos más abogados
no pueden recientemente levantó una mano
en el debate
y dijo que iba a dar de manera gratuita
sus dólares para los ilegales dándole el
servicio de salud lo que va a atraer aún
más ilegales en cifras masivas personas
que van a entrar al país y van a obtener
todas las cosas que quieren educación
salud todo también apoya las ciudades
santuario que protegen a los ilegales
criminales prometió acabar con
las prohibiciones de viaje de naciones y
cadistas y también a aumentar
la llegada a refugiados en un 700 por
ciento esto está en él se manifestó el
plan de bailén va a eliminar las
fronteras del país en medio de una
pandemia mundial e incluso está hablando
de acabar con el muro de tumbar lo que
tal eso
también se opone a la elección libre de
escuelas todas las escuelas chárter
acabando con las oportunidades para los
niños hispanos y afroamericanos yo voy a
expandir esas escuelas y le daré la
opción a las familias de elegir la
escuela que quieren para sus hijos
y siempre vamos a tratar a nuestros
maestros con un respeto tremendo el que
merecen
grandes personas grandes personas job
aiden dice que tiene empatía que siente
empatía por los vulnerables y el partido
que lidera apoya los abortos en estado
avanzado de bebés inocentes
los líderes demócratas hablan de
decencia moral pero no tienen problema
con detener el corazón latiente de un
bebé en el noveno mes de embarazo los
políticos demócratas se rehúsan a
proteger las vidas inocentes y después
nos dan clases de moralidad
y de salvar el alma de eeuu hoy
declaramos de manera orgullosa que todos
los niños nacidos si no tienen un
derecho a la vida
[Aplausos]
demócrata
las palabras bajo dios se eliminaron el
juramento de lealtad de lealtad no una
sino dos veces nosotros nunca haríamos
algo así pero el hecho es que
aquí es de dónde vienen
si la izquierda obtiene poder va a
acabar con los suburbios van a confiscar
sus armas y va a designar jueces que van
a acabar con su segunda enmienda y con
otros otras libertades constitucionales
bailén es un caballo de troya para el
socialismo no tiene la fortaleza para
enfrentarse a marxistas como bernie
sanders y sus otros radicales de los
cuales hay muchos nos vemos todo el
tiempo es algo realmente increíble
entonces como se va a enfrentar o como
se va a levantar para defenderlos a
ustedes el aspecto más peligroso de la
plataforma de biden es el ataque a la
seguridad pública el manifesto de verón
y bailén pide acabar con las fianzas en
efectivo lo cual liberaría a miles de
criminales en sus barrios y cuando le
preguntan si apoya recortar los fondos
para lados para la policía el responde
sí absolutamente cuando la congresista
y la llamó a la policía de mirada por un
cáncer podrido hasta la raíz él no iba
a rechazar su apoyo
poco después incluso lo mostró en su
página web con grandes letras no se
equivoquen si le dan poder a joe biden a
la izquierda radical va a desfinanciar
los departamentos de policía en todo el
país
van a aprobar leyes federales para
reducir la policía a nivel nacional van
a hacer que cada ciudad se ve como
portland oregón nadie estaría seguro en
eeuu de baile en mi administración
siempre va a defender a los hombres y
mujeres de las autoridades
cada día los oficiales de la policía
arriesgan sus vidas para mantenernos
seguros y cada año muchos sacrifican sus
vidas en la línea de deber
uno de ellos fue él
fue miembro de la policía de nueva york
y recibimos su apoyo apenas hace unos
días son grandes personas
[Aplausos]
si se les permitiera hacer su trabajo no
tendrían crimen en nueva york' y rudy
giuliani lo sabe perfectamente hace 3
años el 4 de julio el detective familia
estaba trabajando cuando fue emboscada
después de la medianoche y asesinado por
un monstruo que lo odiaba simplemente
por llevar la placa
recientemente pidió tiempo libre la
madre para poder pasar más tiempo con
sus hijos y estuve en el capitolio con
esos hijos hermosos y la tomé la mano de
su abuela mientras sentían el dolor por
su pérdida terrible y honramos al
detective de familia y su
vida los tres hijos del detective
familias están con nosotros aquí esta
noche danés peter de laila nos sentimos
tan orgullosos de tenerlos aquí esta
noche muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vamos a llevar a su madre en nuestros
corazones para siempre debemos recordar
que la gran mayoría de los oficiales de
la policía son buenos y esa es la
abrumadora mayoría son nobles llenos de
coraje y tenemos que darle a los
oficiales
el poder de nuevo
[Aplausos]
podría perder sus pensiones tienen miedo
de perder sus empleos y al estar
asustados no son capaces de hacer el
trabajo que tan desesperadamente tienen
que hacer por ustedes y aquellos que
sufren más son las grandes personas que
protegen y que quieren proteger a un
nivel incluso mayor cuando hay
injusticias en ese sistema se debe hacer
que estas personas rindan cuentas de
manera total y así será pero nunca
podemos tener una situación donde las
cosas estén como están hoy nunca debemos
permitir que la hace muchedumbres
liberen
[Aplausos]
en los términos más fuertes en el
partido republicano condena los saqueos
los incendios que hemos visto así como
los disturbios particularmente en
ciudades lideradas por demócratas como
portland que no sé y otras hay peligro
en las calles de las ciudades liberadas
por demócratas del país y este problema
se podría arreglar rápidamente si
quisieran simplemente llamen estamos
listos para entrar en nos vamos a ocupar
de su problema en cuestión de horas
simplemente llamen tenemos que esperar
su llamada tenemos que esperar que nos
llamen más siempre tenemos que tener ley
y orden todos ese crimen federal está
siendo perseguido con todo el peso de la
ley
cuando los anarquistas empezaron a
acabar con nuestros monumentos y
estatuas aquí afuera yo firmé una orden
de manera inmediata diez años de prisión
y fue un milagro todo se detuvo
dejaron de tumbar las estatuas cuando
miraron las estatuas decían diez años es
mucho tiempo vamos a casa
durante su convención núcleo bailen y lo
apoyan y se mantuvieron en silencio
sobre estos criminales y agitadores que
generan ese caos en las ciudades
demócratas ni siquiera lo mencionaron
durante toda la convención ni una sola
vez ahora están comenzando a mencionarlo
porque están bajando
sus cifras de aprobación es demasiado
tarde
ante la anarquía de izquierda en
minneapolis chicago y otras ciudades
joe biden y su campaña no la condenaron
al contrario donar al menos 13 miembros
de la campaña de biden donaron fondos
para sacar a estos anarquistas a estos
agitadores y aquí esta noche está la
familia de el capitán david turner un
veterano de 20 años de la policía de san
luís un gran hombre y un hombre muy
respetado por todos y en junio el
capital
fue asesinado cuando estaba tratando de
proteger una tienda de los agitadores y
de los saqueadores o como dirían los
demócratas manifestantes pacíficos les
dicen manifestantes pacíficos estamos
honrados de estar aquí esta noche
con su magnífica esposa anne y sus
hermanos que ley en nunca vamos a
olvidar los el legado heroico del
capitán david turnos muchas gracias por
estar aquí
muchas gracias un gran hombre
mientras yo sea presidente voy a
defender el derecho de cada ciudadano
estadounidense a vivir en seguridad
dignidad y paz si el partido demócrata
quiere quedarse de lado los anarquistas
los aplicadores los saqueadores y los
incendiarios ese es su problema pero
mientras yo sea su presidente no seremos
parte de esto el partido republicano
será y seguirá siendo la voz de los
héroes patriotas que mantienen eeuu
segura y salud haremos la bandera
estadounidense
[Aplausos]
el año pasado más de 1000 afroamericanos
fueron asesinados como el resultado de
la violencia en ciudades lideradas por
demócratas y en el top 10 de las
ciudades más peligrosas del país todas
son lideradas por demócratas y ha sido
así durante décadas miles de
afroamericanos son víctimas
del crimen violento en estas comunidades
yo bailé ni la izquierda ignoran a estos
víctimas estadounidenses yo nunca lo
haré si la izquierda radical toma el
poder van a aplicar sus políticas para
cada ciudad suburbio pueblo del país
simplemente imaginen si los llamados
manifestantes pacíficos estuvieran a
cargo de cada
a nivel de poder en el gobierno
estadounidense estos políticos dicen
estar preocupados por la fortaleza de
las instituciones estadounidenses pero
quien exactamente las está atacando
quien está contratando a estos los
jueces y quien está tratando de acabar
con la aplicación de la ley migratoria y
creando
códigos de discurso para acallar a otros
siempre se trata de miembros de la
izquierda radical siempre recuerden que
vienen detrás de mí porque yo estoy
luchando por ustedes eso es lo que
ocurre
desde incluso antes de que me eligieran
y recuerden estos ellos esperaron mi
campaña y fueron atrapados ahora veamos
qué ocurre tenemos que retomar nuestra
independencia de los mandatos represivos
de la izquierda eeuu estadounidenses
están exhaustos tratando de mantenerse
con la nueva lista de palabras y frases
aprobadas en un mundo cada vez más
restrictivo y sus decretos políticos
muchas cosas tienen un nombre distinto
ahora y las reglas están cambiando
constantemente el objetivo de la cultura
de la cancelación es asegurarse que
muchos vivan en el miedo sean puestos
bajo vergüenza humillados y eliminados
de la sociedad como tal
izquierda radical quieren llevarlos a
decir lo que ustedes saben que es falso
y asustarlos para que no digan lo que
saben que es cierto eso es algo muy
triste
pero el 3 de noviembre ustedes pueden
enviarles un mensaje poderoso que nunca
van a olvidar
gracias
[Aplausos]
es débil en tomar sus órdenes de los
hipócritas liberales que acaban con sus
ciudades mientras se alejan de los
lugares del caos estos mismos liberales
quieren eliminar con la elección libre
de escuelas
quieren abrir nuestras fronteras
mientras viven en sitios cerrados y en
comunidades en los mejores barrios del
mundo quieren desfinanciar a la policía
mientras ellos tienen guardias armados
particulares y en noviembre debemos
voltear la página
a esta clase política fallida el hecho
es que yo estoy aquí
cómo se llama este edificio
pero lo diré de otra manera el hecho es
que nosotros estamos aquí y ellos no
guarde más para mí uno de los edificios
más bellos del mundo no es un edificio
es un hogar en lo que a mí respecta no
es una casa es un hogar es un lugar
hermoso con una historia increíble pero
es todo por ustedes juntos vamos a
escribir el nuevo capítulo de la gran
historia estadounidense en los próximos
cuatro años vamos a hacer que eeuu sea
un superpoder de manufactura en el mundo
vamos a expandir las zonas de
oportunidad
gracias a team scot nos vamos a traer a
casa a nuestras cadenas de suministro
médico
mantenemos la resiliencia
no vamos a depender ni un poco de china
vamos a sacar nuestros negocios de china
los estamos trayendo de nuevo a casa
queremos que estos negocios regresen a
casa y continuaremos reduciendo los
impuestos y las regulaciones a niveles
que nunca antes se han visto vamos a
crear 10 millones de empleos en los
próximos 10 meses y será incluso más que
eso vamos a contratar a más policía a
aumentar más que carlos castigos para
aquellos que ataquen a los oficiales y
ya veremos oficiales a las comunidades
con altos tasas de criminalidad nos
aseguraremos que la salud sea protegida
para los ciudadanos y no para los
ilegales
tenemos fronteras fuertes
lo he dicho durante años sin fronteras
no tenemos país
y acabaremos los terroristas que
amenazan a nuestro pueblo y mantendremos
a eeuu lejos de las guerras
interminables en el exterior
y vamos a designar jueces y fiscales que
crean en aplicar la ley y no en aplicar
su propia agenda política
lo cual es ilegal vamos a asegurar
justicia igualitaria para personas de
todas las razas religiones colores
credos vamos a respetar sus libertades
religiosas y defender su derecho a
portar y poseer armas
[Aplausos]
y si logramos su segunda enmienda no
tiene ni una sola oportunidad eso se los
puedo decir yo lo he protegido
vamos a proteger a medicare y a la
seguridad social siempre de manera
fuerte vamos a proteger los pacientes
con condiciones preexistentes y esa es
una promesa de todo el partido
republicano gracias que vine
y vamos a acabar con las cuentas médicas
sorpresa pidiendo y exigiendo
transparencia y reduciendo los precios
de las primas de salud así como de los
medicamentos por prescripción vamos a
expandir el desarrollo energético
continuando siendo el número uno en el
mundo y manteniendo a eeuu
independiente de energéticamente
y para ustedes que aún tienen un auto
miren el precio de la gasolina lo han
visto tan bajo
[Aplausos]
vamos a ganar la carrera del 5g y
construir en los mejores sistemas de
defensa y de misiles que ya están bajo
construcción vamos a restaurar
completamente la educación patriótica a
nuestras escuelas para siempre proteger
siempre siempre proteger la libertad de
expresión en las universidades
[Aplausos]
y pusimos un gran castigo ahí no tiene
nada que ver si se mete con la libertad
de expresión las universidades tienen un
gran precio por pagar y es impresionante
lo abiertas que han estado últimamente
lanzaremos una nueva era de ambición en
el espacio de eeuu llevará a la primera
mujer a la mujer a la luna y seremos la
primera nación en plantar su hermosa
bandera en marte
[Aplausos]
esta es la agenda nacional unificadora
que va a unir este país entonces esta
noche le digo a todos los
estadounidenses que esta es la elección
más importante en la historia del país
nunca ha habido una diferencia tan
grande entre dos partidos dos individuos
dos ideologías dos filosofías o dos
visiones que en la que existe en este
momento mis oponentes creen que estados
unidos es una nación depravadas nosotros
queremos que nuestros hijos e hijas
conozcan la verdad estados unidos es la
nación más excepcional y más grande en
la historia del mundo
[Aplausos]
nuestro país no fue construido por la
cultura de la cancelación o por códigos
de diálogo no somos una nación de
espíritu tímido somos una
nación de personas independientes
patriotas y dolorosas somos una nación
de pioneros aventureros exploradores
personas que se rehúsan a ser amarrados
de ninguna manera los estadounidenses
tienen lo mejor en su mente tienen gran
alma y tienen fuego en su corazón no hay
nadie como nosotros en la tierra quiero
que cada niño en este país sepa que
ustedes son parte de la mayor aventura y
la más emocionante en la historia de la
humanidad sin importar de donde vengan
sus familias sin importar cuáles sean
sus orígenes cualquiera aquí puede
triunfar con trabajo duro devoción y
determinación pueden alcanzar cualquier
objetivo y cualquier ambición nuestros
ancestros
navegaron por el océano para construir
una nueva vida en un nuevo continente se
enfrentaron a los inviernos cruzaron los
ríos
subieron los picos se enfrentaron a los
peligros del bosque y avanzaron desde el
amanecer hasta el anochecer no tenían
dinero no tenían fama pero se tenían
unos abuelos amaban a sus familias
amaban a su país y amaban a su dios
cuando se presentó la oportunidad
tomaron sus biblias
empacaron se subieron a sus vagones y se
fueron hacia el oeste para la próxima
aventura los rancheros los mineros y los
cowboys y los yaris los campesinos
pasaron por el mississippi
para crear nuevas fronteras
nacieron leyendas
y construyeron sus casas hermosas tiene
sus órganos tuvieron después comunidades
después pueblos y con el tiempo grandes
centros de industria y comercio
eso es lo que ellos fueran los
estadounidenses crearon su futuro
nosotros no vivamos en el pasado somos
la nación
que ganó una revolución que acabó con el
fascismo y la tiranía y que llevó a
miles a la libertad
construimos los ferrocarriles los
grandes buques creamos los edificios más
altos del mundo revolucionando las
industrias y creando una nueva era de
descubrimientos científicos creamos las
tendencias en arte o música en radio y
en el cine y en el deporte en la
literatura y lo hicimos todo con steve
de confianza porque eso es lo que somos
cuando nuestra manera de vida se ha
visto amenazada nuestros héroes
respondieron al llamado desde que los
estadounidenses se levantaron con balas
y bayonetas para rescatar la libertad no
tuvieron miedo pero eeuu no se detuvo
ahí miramos hacia el cielo y seguimos
avanzando
construiremos construimos un cohete y lo
lanzamos al espacio lo hicimos para que
esos grandes patriotas pudieran saludar
nuestra maravillosa bandera
estadounidense plantada en la superficie
de la luna para eeuu nada es imposible
los próximos cuatro años vamos a probar
que somos dignos de este maravilloso
legado alcanzando nuevas alturas y
mostraremos que el mundo
para eeuu existe un sueño y no está más
allá de su alcance juntos somos no nadie
nos pueda detener nadie nos puede
derrotar porque juntos somos los
ciudadanos orgullosos de los eeuu de
américa
y el 3 de noviembre
[Aplausos]
haremos que eeuu se sea más seguro vamos
a hacer que este país sea más fuerte
haremos que el país sea más orgulloso y
haremos que eeuu sea más grande de lo
que nunca jamás ha sido que estoy muy
pero muy orgulloso de ser el nominado
del partido republicano los amo a todos
que dios los bendiga dios bendiga a
estados
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y con estas palabras del presidente de
eeuu donald trump finaliza la convención
nacional republicana que se desarrolló
durante cuatro días de manera mayormente
virtual también con algunos eventos
presenciales como el que estamos viendo
en este momento desde la casa blanca y
como estaba previsto se han lanzado
fuegos artificiales desde las
inmediaciones de algunos de los
monumentos más importantes de la ciudad
de washington dc
donald trump usó como bandera de su
discurso lo que dice ha sido una lucha
por los trabajadores desde que inició su
mandato mientras que según él dijo
bardem envió los trabajos a china
destacó la firma del teme que el nuevo
acuerdo comercial con méxico y con
canadá y que muchas más compañías
gracias a eso construyen en eeuu y
destacó entre ellas a las compañías
automotrices también habló de las
fronteras estadounidenses dijo que son
más seguras hay que se han construido
300 millas de muro y que se agregan 10
millas cada semana asegura que muy
pronto va a estar terminado y
funcionando
también habló de las victorias contra el
estado islámico al matar a abu bakr al
bagdadí y que se crearon o se están
creando tratamientos en eeuu contra el
joven 19 como el plasma convaleciente
dice donald trump que van a aplastar el
hobbit 19 que están muy cerca de
alcanzar una vacuna este año en eeuu y
por supuesto ha lanzado fuertes críticas
contra su contrincante por la casa
blanca el 3 de noviembre de joe biden a
quien ha acusado de pedir un aumento de
los impuestos en 4 millones de cuatro
millones de dólares y por supuesto
donald trump también ha utilizado otra
de sus banderas de campaña que es hacer
que eeuu sea más seguro en este
siguiente periodo mientras que sucede en
estos actos desde la casa blanca pues ya
también hay reacciones por parte del
lado demócrata y es que efectivamente yo
by the n emitió un trino opinando sobre
el discurso de donald trump vamos a ver
de qué se trata y dice donald trump se
hace llamar a sí mismo como un
presidente en tiempos de guerra pero
ahora en vez de liderar la ofensiva para
vencer al virus el ondeo la bandera
blanca abandonó el pueblo estadounidense
cuando más lo necesitaba
sabiendo que el empleo ha sido una de
las prioridades de donald trump y uno de
los puntos que más destacó durante el
discurso de esta noche vamos a revisar
cuál ha sido la situación de empleo en
eeuu que es bastante particular vamos a
revisarla desde febrero en ese mes el
país gozaba de la tasa de desempleo más
baja en medio siglo que era del 35 por
ciento pero desde que inició la pandemia
se disparó rápidamente hasta alcanzar un
máximo desde la gran depresión de la
década de los 30 y llegó al 14,7 por
ciento desde entonces se ha venido
desacelerando y ya está en poco más del
10% aunque aún sigue siendo una tasa muy
alta
con estos datos los voy a regresar con
nuestras tres invitadas de esta noche
que pacientemente han estado esperando
por la finalización de este discurso
para poder brindarnos el análisis
estamos con antonella martí analista
política desde washington dc icono maría
herrera quien es estratega republicana y
bueno la pregunta que les quiero hacer
es precisamente sobre las imágenes que
acabamos de ver del empleo
es realmente donald trump un campeón por
los trabajadores teniendo en cuenta pues
que no le ha ido bien especialmente por
la pandemia de kobe 19 y el desempleo ha
aumentado tanto empiezo con ustedes
maría
bueno yo creo que donald trump ha
demostrado la capacidad de gestión y de
creación de empleo durante todo su
mandato a lo largo de su mandato
evidentemente la pandemia le ha afectado
nos ha afectado a todos los
estadounidenses y estamos en un proceso
de recuperación pero si miramos el
mercado la creación de empleo y los
números de desempleo si los comparamos
con estos números con los existentes en
otros países definitivamente tenemos que
decir que donald trump está haciendo un
presidente ejemplar en materia de
creación de empleo yo creo que es hay un
candidato a la presidencia a tener muy
en cuenta y por supuesto un presidente
que ha luchado fervientemente por traer
los empleos de vuelta a eeuu
antonella usted qué opina acerca de este
donald trump que se presenta como el
campeón del empleo y de los trabajadores
en eeuu es un discurso creíble
a ver yo creo que todos estos aspectos
también hay que tomarlos con pinzas no
yo creo que hay una cuestión acá de
coyuntura eso es cierto lo que hemos
vivido este año con la crisis del coi 19
algo que nadie se esperaba que sucediera
pero también hay números y aspectos que
no se están teniendo en cuenta a la hora
de hablar sobre la realidad no solo
económica de los eeuu sino también
política y social ahora teniendo en
cuenta toda esta este sector o esta idea
yo creo y después de haber escuchado
completo el discurso del presidente de
donald trump la verdad que me preocupa
mucho la caída en la calidad política
norteamericana vemos que ambos
candidatos y de ambos lados no tanto del
lado demócrata como el lado republicano
parece ser que todo se resuelve al menos
en lo que escucho y también en lo que
hemos visto en los en la acción todo se
resuelve con mayor gasto público y
muchas veces apelando a los sentimientos
llegan a decir qué
a ver mi análisis a todo esto es que hoy
en día la presencia de un donald trump
en los eeuu es también una consecuencia
de barack obama una persona que empezó a
desmantelar el estado de derecho yo creo
que esos son aspectos que tenemos que
tener en cuenta a la hora de evaluar o
hacer un análisis de esta perspectiva
respecto de la economía de la
administración de donald trump
y su análisis de cuál sería maría
después de escuchar este discurso de más
de 40 minutos en los que bueno el
mandatario hizo un resumen bastante
amplio de cuatro años de gobierno
bueno a mí me ha encantado el discurso
yo creo que ha sido un repaso de los
éxitos cosechados en durante esto
durante haré su mandato tanto en
política exterior como en seguridad
nacional sanidad defensa y la verdad que
los que vivimos en eeuu hemos disfrutado
de una prosperidad sin precedentes de
una seguridad en los mercados de trabajo
si miramos los datos de la bolsa a día
de hoy son magníficos teniendo en cuenta
como decía antonella la coyuntura en la
que nos encontramos y yo creo que la
oferta del presidente es clara un país
más seguro es lo que queremos los países
seguros es donde prosperan las personas
apela a la defensa de la libertad
individual es algo que me encanta es
algo de lo que nosotros nos sentimos muy
orgullosos y los datos que han dado y
las las políticas que ofrece donald
trump yo creo que son la clave del éxito
en comparación tenemos a un
vicepresidente perdón a un candidato a
la presidencia a un antiguo
vicepresidente que hoy mismo le
preguntaban en la televisión acerca del
delito el incidente de estos de estos
policías que habían disparado a un
afroamericano y lo confundía con un niño
de 17 años que no tenía nada que ver con
la víctima en este caso yo creo que
estamos perdidos y llevados nos van a
llevar por muy mal camino si dejamos que
los demócratas gobiernen que le tiendan
la mano a cuba a venezuela levanten las
sanciones y que definitivamente como ha
resumido muy bien
donald trump que yo bailén de nuevo
permita que china lidere el orden
mundial porque como hemos podido ver
china es un país comunista que ha
resultado ser desastroso y un último
punto y yo no estoy completamente de
acuerdo con que donald trump
y han mantenido ese gasto en incesante
en lo público porque también es verdad
que ha habido muchísimos recortes por
ejemplo se salió de la organización
mundial de la salud y ha recortado
muchos muchas digamos financiación en el
ámbito también de los servicios de
inmigración está profesionalizando la
inmigración y yo creo que sí donald
trump gana tenemos los estadounidense a
un futuro esperanzador y el resto del
mundo será un lugar más seguro para
vivir
sobre eso quiero hablar también
antonella eeuu es y será un lugar más
seguro bajo el segundo mandato o posible
segundo mandato que al que aspira donald
trump
no mientras la libertad siga en peligro
yo recién toda esta trayectoria en lo
que va de la noche he tomado nota de
varias de varios aspectos julian y decía
en un momento que el partido demócrata
está completamente tirado a la izquierda
esto lo dijo es julián y es cierto pero
el partido republicano está totalmente
tirado hacia la derecha y la libertad
digo no está ni a la derecha ni a la
izquierda ni en el centro por eso creo
que ni los conservadores ni los
socialistas están a la altura de la
libertad porque porque para ellos la
libertad se corta en tajos para ellos la
libertad se divide y yo lo que estoy
viendo hoy en este escenario político
norteamericano es una lucha
prácticamente de ideologías donde se
está proponiendo gobernar en base al
miedo por un lado al partido demócrata
no que hoy está repleto de estos
personajes que varían bastante en su
grado ideológico de tendencias de la
izquierda claramente y que va mucho más
allá de hablar de socialdemocracia
porque digamos el grado de socialismo en
mucho de estos personajes dentro del
partido demócrata es realmente
preocupante
y lo digo como latinoamericana y desde
un país populista como argentina que
hace 80 años está sumergido en el
peronismo es muy preocupante el
surgimiento de las figuras políticas que
están teniendo los eeuu vuelvo a
insistir tanto de izquierda como de
derecha dentro del partido demócrata
personalidades como alexander ocasio
cortes quien negó a ejercer una condena
este hacia la persona de nicolás maduro
este sanguinario dictador narco criminal
desde venezuela o incluso teniendo unos
personajes como bernie sanders que bien
sabemos cuáles son la trayectoria de
estos personajes pero sí me parece muy
preocupante ver el surgimiento de estas
de estas figuras ahora por otro lado
sobre el presidente de donald trump yo
creo que es indudable y no se puede
digamos negar que ha aumentado
sideralmente el gasto público el déficit
la deuda gubernamental con todo lo que
aumentó el tamaño del estado además creo
que es algo que los padres fundadores de
los estados unidos no podrían ni
comprender y yo a ver hoy veo algunas
personas que muchos se dicen liberales
o que se dicen lo que creen defender la
libertad pero claramente son
conservadores o nación
donald trump por haber bajado algunos
impuestos como lo es de hecho el
impuesto corporativo por ejemplo que se
bajó del 35 al 21 pero por otro lado
este mismo presidente abbas ha hecho la
división de los poderes a ver lo hemos
visto extralimitarse muchas veces es un
proteccionista confesó haber su
nacionalismo económico ha afectado a
tantos socios comerciales a lo largo del
mundo y en la región también su
proteccionismo ese presupuesto tan
keynesiano digamos para ir cerrando a la
idea
trump habla de hacer a eeuu grandes de
nuevo no ese es el gran lema de su
campaña constante y eso quiere decir que
en otro momento eeuu fue grande y fue
grande en sus comienzos fue grande
cuando el gobierno estaba controlado y
vigilado cuando el gobierno no
sobrepasaba los límites cuando se
respetaba esa división de poderes cuando
el libre mercado era el lema de los eeuu
sin tener que recurrir a las falsas
políticas públicas de los aranceles y
proteccionismos como cada uno de los
candidatos que hoy están tanto el lado
republicano como demócrata
proponiendo con tanto estado y los eeuu
si fueron grandes con los padres
fundadores y ninguno de estos dos
candidatos yo creo que respetan a
rajatablas las ideas de los padres
fundadores así que sí es muy peligroso
el camino por el que está transitando a
los eeuu sin dudas bueno pero entonces
vamos a lo práctico
mariah vamos a hacer una revisión de las
encuestas en este momento joe biden
tiene 47 por ciento de los apoyos y
donald trump el 40 por ciento según el
último sondeo que realizó la agencia
reuters con ipsos y esto sucedió del 19
al 25 de agosto es decir es muy reciente
con un margen de error además bajo puede
donald trump cambiar estas encuestas o
que diría usted de estos números
bueno yo creo que sí desde luego y
además tenemos como referencia a las
elecciones del 2016 donde nadie apostaba
por el candidato donald trump y hasta el
último momento nos auguraban una
victoria de hillary clinton además como
yo indicaba al inicio del programa es
cierto que hay una minoría silenciosa
cada vez menos silenciosa que yo creo
que va a salir a votar por por donald
trump y lo creo porque mientras las
manifestaciones y no el estallido social
que estamos viviendo la inseguridad la
intranquilidad y todo lo que está
aconteciendo yo creo que esto son
votantes que como venía reivindicando lo
que buscan es seguridad y que el
candidato que a día de hoy ofrece
seguridad si bien que para algunos la
tachan de seguridad ficticia es donald
trump porque desde el otro lado pues
hemos visto qué
no solo inclusive no solo los demócratas
sino muchos
alcaldes y gobernadores republicanos no
han sido capaz de defender las ciudades
en el caso por ejemplo de la cancelación
de la cultura el derribo de las estatuas
mucho del legado español en los eeuu ha
sido realmente vergonzoso lo que hemos
vivido aquí estamos en los eeuu donde
los políticos no se quiere mojar
demasiado donde tienen miedo ellos
mismos a definirse y el único digamos
representante político que se ha
mantenido firme o los únicos
representantes nacido donald trump y
michaels y bueno yo creo que es la
agenda de donald trump en materia
pro-vida en materia de seguridad
nacional acuerdos de paz
y si bien estoy de acuerdo con mantener
la que es cuestionable
en ciertos aspectos proteccionistas
desde el punto de vista liberal yo creo
que mejor desde luego la agenda
conservadora de donald trump yo creo que
al final va a convencer a muchísimos
millones de estadounidenses y en
concreto hablo como el fna cada vez veo
más que los gitanos se animan por votar
y apoyar al presidente de ausbanc bueno
y sin embargo hay algunos eventos que
pueden ponerlos no dudar por ejemplo
esta semana 27 ex congresistas cambiaron
de bando y decidieron empezar a apoyar a
joe biden y entonces le lanzó la misma
pregunta ya para el cierre antonella y
es puede donald trump todavía girar el
resultado de los apoyos y de las
encuestas porque hasta antes de la
pandemia podría aparecer que tenía una
victoria mucho más segura pero en este
momento se le ha cuestionado con mucha
más fuerza
y la verdad es que esto no es no es para
nada predecible no uno no sabe hasta
último momento cómo va a darse esta
situación incluso puede pasar cualquier
cuestión de coyuntura que que cambie
todo este pero si vuelvo a insistir yo
creo que al menos los modales de el
presidente donald trump no son los
propios para una presidencia en un país
serio como los eeuu solicitó sus malas
maneras a la hora de referirse a jueces
que tal vez han emitido fallos en su
contra o sus ofensas las guerras
comerciales esto es lo que lo hemos
venido hablando algo que encabeza la
xenofobia los maltratos yo creo que hay
una caída verdaderamente preocupante de
la calidad institucional con personas
hacia la cabeza de un país como los eeuu
y esto es algo que no es sólo no es sólo
algo que afecta a los eeuu un fenómeno
que afecta únicamente a los estados
unidos es algo que abarca me atrevo a
decir a iberoamérica no vemos el
resurgir de tantos movimientos
populistas tanto de izquierda como de
derecha y eso es algo realmente
preocupante porque ninguno de los dos
están de la mano de la libertad de
proteger verdad
la libertad económica política
individual que es tan importante
yo espero verdaderamente que los eeuu
puedan volver a recuperar esos valores y
principios reales de los de los padres
fundadores representando no es a esa
tradición liberal pero sumando a esto la
importancia de las libertades
individuales como el respeto a la
comunidad lgbt el respeto a las
decisiones personales de los individuos
sin tener un gobierno que trate a los
individuos como si fueran sus hijos o
como si fueran niños creo que es
importante destacar las libertades
también para consumir lo que uno quiera
hacer lo que uno quiera con su propio
cuerpo teniendo siempre por supuesto a
la par de la libertad la la
responsabilidad y el respeto por por los
proyectos de vida de los demás
a ver yo creo que acá tenemos que
debatir ciertos aspectos como lo son por
ejemplo ponerle fin a la guerra fallida
contra las drogas eso es algo que lo
estamos viendo en algo que no ha
funcionado esa guerra contra las drogas
que ninguno de estos dos candidatos se
atreve a acabar o a terminar digamos ha
fracasado rotundamente como fracaso en
los años veinte
ley seca los eeuu la prohibición del
alcohol
ahora está fracasando y sigue fracasando
desde el siglo pasado esta guerra que se
ha encabezado desde los eeuu a las
drogas y algo que ha afectado mucho a
américa latina entonces por qué no
empezar a hablar de la importancia de la
legalización de las drogas y acabar
finalmente con esa guerra fallida contra
contra las drogas yo no vuelvo a
insistir no tenemos que quedarnos
solamente en la obe hay otras personas
que también están poniendo sobre la mesa
de estos aspectos vuelvo a insistir el
partido libertario con joe jørgensen a
la cabeza yo creo que también es una
alternativa para ponerle los ojos y
tener en cuenta que no es solamente
quedarse el socialismo o conservadurismo
o tener que adaptarse a votar al mal
menor sin embargo en este momento las
opciones son claras a la presidencia y
son o joe biden o donald trump
muchísimas gracias a ustedes antonio la
marca en la lista política desde
washington dc y maría herrera estratega
republicana desde la florida me despido
de ustedes y regresó rápidamente con
nuestras corresponsales en washington
diana castañeda y en nueva york
mamen sala ellas han estado con nosotros
escucha
todo este evento toda esta noche todas
las intervenciones y ya para el cierre
antes de despedirnos lo que quiero
pedirles es a cada una sus conclusiones
como periodistas que además tendrán que
cubrir de aquí a noviembre lo que suceda
también comienzo con usted
sí pues ha sido un discurso desde luego
bastante completo sí que me ha llamado
la atención que ha sido en algunos
momentos contradictorio ha planteado ha
puesto encima de la mesa soluciones para
frenar la expansión del cob y 19 pero sí
que es verdad que hemos visto una
audiencia en vivo de al menos 1500
personas con mucha ausencia de
mascarillas poco distanciamiento social
en un momento en el que precisamente se
invita a eso a que no se reúnan muchas
personas también es interesante lo que
ha dicho acerca de la economía es verdad
que cuando en febrero la economía la
tasa de desempleo estaba en un 3,4 por
ciento pero también es cierto que
debemos pensar en cuánto estaba esa
economía en el 2016 y que estaba
alrededor de un 4% también ha habido
algunos puntos pues que entiendo que en
su discurso ha tenido que ponerlos en
valor y llevarlos a su terreno pero a
veces difieren un poco de la realidad de
eeuu se recupera rápidamente
económicamente eso habría que ponerlo un
poco en cuarentena por así decirlo sobre
todo porque en el segundo trimestre del
año el pib ha caído casi un 31 por
encima un 31 por ciento así que bueno ha
sido un discurso bastante completo
ha conseguido hasta ahora y lo que
espera poner encima de la mesa en los
cuatro próximos años desde luego no se
esperaba ese concierto al final de esta
jornada teniendo en cuenta la situación
pandémica en la que nos encontramos y ha
sido una convención que no ha tenido
nada que ver con la que veíamos la
semana anterior mucho más virtual
mascarillas y con mucho más presencia de
la situación que estamos viviendo
actualmente y eso habla mucho de la
realidad republicana y también de la
realidad demócrata y diana rápidamente
ya nos quedan pocos minutos
si puedes donald trump se ha presentado
en este discurso como el único líder que
puede restablecer el orden en medio de
estas protestas en los pasados meses en
búsqueda de justicia social y también el
único que puede llevar al crecimiento
económico proponiendo 10 millones de
trabajos en los próximos 10 meses una
meta muy ambiciosa y uno de los temas
más esperados será definitivamente el
manejo que va a dar al tema de la
pandemia hablando de reapertura de
negocios de enviar a los niños a las
escuelas pero dijo y no digamos obvio
algunas cifras importantes como más de
170 mil personas que han perdido la vida
en los eeuu por culpa de el coronavirus
al igual que cerca de los 20 millones de
personas que están desempleadas
actualmente así que vemos una diferencia
con la agenda que está proponiendo del
otro lado del partido demócrata y
consideró también que uno de los temas
que también llama más la atención
que veíamos en la convención demócrata
cómo se utilizaron permanentemente
términos como que la democracia estaba
en riesgo
racismo en los eeuu y del lado
republicano palabras como por ejemplo el
anarquismo comunismo socialismo lo que
muestra claramente la polarización en la
que están los dos partidos de cara a lo
que serán estas elecciones
presidenciales
muchas gracias a ustedes mamen que
tengan una feliz noche y de esta manera
pues llegamos al final les propusimos
hace dos semanas un cubrimiento y un
análisis de ambas convenciones en eeuu
de cara a las elecciones del 3 de
noviembre y cumplimos con la
satisfacción de ese deber cumplido
llegamos al final de esta transmisión
pero los esperamos mañana muy temprano
porque seguimos informando de américa
latina y del mundo
esto es france24 buenas noches
[Música]